What hotel?
We're on the air right now and I'm going to tweet and talk at the same time,
folks.
That's how I go.
That's how rose.
Here we go.
I don't even have to look at this fucking scream and that's how good on that.
I'm gonna go with you dirty bitches.
You do your t p t c h e s,
http colon backslash,
but I do it all by hand.
Tell you I'm a fucking throw back.
I drive a manual transmission car.
Ladies and gentlemen.
You know why?
Because I'm a fucking man and a man should know how to rope gears.
Okay,
can you shoot?
No.
Around the tree?
Yeah,
I've done that before,
but that's confuses the shit out of me.
A friend had a truck and I was like,
what's going to bill?
Burr has one of those.
He has a three on the tree for folks at home.
Don't know what we're talking about.
Old School trucks especially would have clutches on the floor.
Let me just do this commercial quick.
We'll talk about cars.
The Joe Rogan experience podcast is brought to you by a bunch of shit.
That's groovy.
Okay.
One of them is death squad.
Dot.
TV.
If you look at desk [inaudible] dot TV,
that's where all the dope kitty cat shirts that Brian designs are a for sale.
Tate Fletcher's with us today.
He is old school.
Oh Gee.
Desk squad member from the day Sohn to the core in the DNA kid.
You can't extract that Shit.
rogan.ting.com is another place you should go.
Oh,
did I say a death squad.
Dot TV.
Go there by the TV.
By the time they buy a TV five by a fucking,
you can't actually through doug.com do that.
And it's another way Brian makes money.
That sneaky little fuck I can buy a new shoe.
If you go to Doug [inaudible] dot com and order,
like if you're going to buy something from Amazon,
Amazon has this crazy program where you,
uh,
you don't have to actually go just through Amazon.
You can have like a little affiliate link up on your site.
So if they want to look at something that go through your site and the person
who wants a site gets like a little kickback,
it's kind of Nice of Amazon to do.
So I think it's a cool thing to support anyway.
So doug.com a way to do that.
Um,
we're also brought to you by Ting Tang is the,
uh,
the mobile company that I've been talking about for awhile.
Uh,
they,
uh,
had been sponsoring us on a,
you know,
kind of an on and off basis,
uh,
just to try it out and it's been working out well.
And the reason why it's been working out well,
it's cause you guys were responding to what they're selling and it's a great
service.
There's no contracts,
right?
The waiting has it set up.
You can,
like,
you could have a whole family on the same amount of time.
There's a,
like if you,
if you don't use a certain amount of minutes per month,
like if you're allotted x amount of minutes and you don't use them,
you get credited to them on the next month.
It's as fair companies you can get.
There's no cancellation fees,
there's no contracts and they use the sprint network.
So it's a solid network.
They just do it in a way that I just think it's like,
it's a smarter move ethically.
Like they're not,
they're not trying to rip anybody off there.
They're not trying to lock you into some stupid ass fucking contract.
Why should,
why should it be even the legal that you can tell me that I have to be with you
even though you suck or if I want to leave I have to pay a fee.
Fuck you.
It's,
that's terrible.
And these guys don't do that.
And that's what I love about Tang.
I think it's a fucking cool company.
It was probably a CIA front approach.
That's probably what it is,
is I'm selling some fucking recording devices and gps track.
No,
I'm not folks.
It's a,
I fucking talk to the guy in the phone.
He seems like it's totally,
the phones they have are the shit too,
by the way.
I like that.
Let's keep doing that in commercials and make it more exciting.
I'm shocked.
Me,
Brian.
Um,
the phones they have are excellent.
The one that I got is a Samsung Galaxy s three.
It's fucking dope.
I have not committed to it as my main phone over my iPhone mostly because I have
to move the context and everything,
but I'm just going to say this,
it shits all over the iPhone.
It shits all over the iPhone.
It's fucking that Samsung Galaxy s three is the shit.
It's huge.
First of all,
you get used to looking at web pages on their big thing and you don't ever want
to go back to an iPhone.
You're like,
it's so stupid.
I could browse the web and actually read a website instead of scrolling to the
left and scrolling to the right and trying to fit it all in like a fucking
caveman.
What that Samsung Galaxy s three,
you can see the whole screen.
They have a bunch of other cool smartphones to,
there's like a wide variety of phones and they even have like if you like old
school flip phone dude,
they've got one of those things to man.
You can a lot of dudes,
they,
even Dana White,
Dana white goes,
he rocks old school who Brock's a flip phone and he texted with one thumb.
Dude is weird,
but that's,
that's all possible on Ting.
Um,
all sorts of different LG mostly.
mostly droid smartphones though and ones that have excellent ratings online too.
If you go and go to like,
um,
uh,
any of the tech sites,
see net along those lines and check out some of the reviews on some of these
phones.
A lot of them are like really bad ass,
especially the galaxy s three.
So go Walter rogan.ting.com and if you sign up for service,
you save 50 bucks off the price of a phone.
Whoa.
Can you believe that shit?
We're also brought to you by [inaudible] dot com that's a alpha brain.
That's my,
um,
that's the one thing that I talk about on this podcast.
Probably more than anything as far as like sponsorships that have really worked
for me is this,
fuck the idea of bottling up the best nootropics.
I'm a big fan of nutrition and health and uh,
and I'm a big fan of supplementation to,
and I think that there are absolutely certain supplements that it can enhance,
can enhance the way your brain functions.
Just like caffeine can pick you up and give you a little boost and give you some
energy,
just like a lot of different nutrients can have a positive effect on athletic
performance.
There are certain compounds that have been shown to clearly have a positive
effect on your brain's ability to function.
Your,
your,
your ability to rattle off sentences,
your ability to recall things that you need to remember.
It's um,
it's just if there are nutrients that help to enhance your brain's ability to
produce neurotransmitters,
all of it can be explained and way more detailed than me because I'm a fucking
idiot and I don't really know what I'm saying.
The things that I'm saying,
it's like I'm saying the right words and the right order,
but what am I saying really?
I don't know.
I really don't know much about neurotransmitters.
If you told me where's the w w where's the neurotransmitter factory?
In the brain.
I was like,
hmm,
I don't know the plumbing.
I don't know where the light switches.
I don't know shit.
But I know when I take Alpha brain,
uh,
first of all,
I have insanely vivid dreams.
That is the one thing that seems nothing seems universal,
which I found really fascinating about this experience getting involved with a
vitamin company is nothing's universal.
There's some people that just do not respond to a lot of different things,
or their sensitivity is different than yours or I don't know,
or their body's different.
There's no doubt about it.
Look,
some people can eat peanuts and they love him.
Some people eat peanuts and they're fucking dead.
Some people can eat shellfish and they love him.
Some people eat shell fish in there fucking debt.
It's weird,
you know,
it's like food for one person is literally poison for the neck,
so our bodies are not the same.
And because of that,
to make sure that no one ever feels ripped off.
One of the things we have at on it is a 100% money back guarantee on the first
30 pills.
You don't have to return the product.
You just say,
the shit is not for me.
It doesn't work for me.
But that's the way it's set up that ways for two reasons.
One,
to ensure you that we're not trying to rip anybody off and everything we sell is
something that I personally stand behind.
My livelihood is not dependent on this.
This is,
this is like some extra money that sponsors the podcast for some shit that I
really believe in that that's how I look at it.
But if I had nothing to do with this,
I would still be raving about this shit because every one of the different
supplements,
whether it's room tech sport,
which is based on the quarter steps mushroom,
that helps,
uh,
it gives you endurance.
All of these things are based on real science and their bay and it's all stuff
that I would take if I had nothing to do with this show.
Go to Joe Rogan.
Dinette check it out.
We also now have kettle bell.
Don't do that.
Yeah.
Now you went over the line and he,
fuck.
See,
that's the story of your life.
That little commercial you became really confusing.
You just fucking marred the message.
I had to get a farts.
Why you're bored.
I was bored.
Will Not stop cause you gotta think this is a job stupid.
It's not.
You know you're actually supposed to be doing something.
Oh shoot here for two minutes.
I've got to make fart noises.
They can't dig it.
Add.
Are you hitting the monkey one or how to get it confused to be like I'm going to
go to parks cause I'm bored.
Yeah.
Well let's see.
Well the bank aren't doing it.
Don't see that there's any other way to do this job.
So on a.com get yourself some kettle bells.
That's the newest thing we have.
We have packages,
all sorts of different packages of different kettle bells.
They're raw.
The best quality they're made by Troy and they will survive the apocalypse and
you will not.
They will be here when new civilizations,
we'll find these fucking bowling balls made of steel with a handle them
on a.com.
Use the code name Brogan.
You'll save 10% off all supplements,
but you won't save shit off of kettle bells or battle ropes because them shits
is expensive.
Them Shits is very expensive,
but although all those supplements and we've got more stuff coming.
Um,
so that's it.
You fucking freaks this weekend.
I'm in North Carolina,
I am in Raleigh,
North Carolina on Friday and I am in Asheville,
North Carolina on Saturday.
If you're interested,
go to my Twitter page and it'll have all the details.
My Twitter pages,
Joe Rogan,
right and fucking freaks.
Tait Fletcher.
See of Brian Red band.
Cue The music,
the Joe Rogan experience.
Joe Rogan podcast by night.
Well
suit this bulletproof coffee that you brought here.
Explain this Tate Tate Fletcher.
Oh Gee,
gangster of the desk squad from from day one.
From day one.
Day One.
Push up to that thing.
All right with that crazy beer.
Yeah.
You got gotta for folks who are just listening to this Tate's rocking a beard,
it looks like it's glued on.
It looks like the fake Rick Ross beard like they were talking about.
He goes to the front gate,
the fake Rick Ross.
Well,
you got to
free freeway,
Rick Ross.
If you haven't listened to those episodes of my podcast,
please do it just for your own edification because it's a fascinating scenario.
Guy Was a big time drug dealers name is freeway,
Rick Ross and went to jail.
I mean he had a freeway,
Rick Ross Task Force and the LAPD,
his drug sales were a part of the Iran contra gate.
All that.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
His drug sales where what's funding foreign militaries.
That's where they were getting the money from the CIA.
And this is all part of how a Gary Webb expose this in a book.
And Michael Rupert who was a la police department,
narcotics officer exposed it.
Yeah.
I mean,
so this guy freeway Rick Ross was a part of this.
He was a huge drug dealer making millions and millions of dollars.
Right?
Just crazy,
crazy money.
Drove around in a hearse,
you know,
like drive around like station wagons and shit.
So like no flashy,
no bling,
just kept it on the DL,
just raking in the cash.
Meanwhile the dude couldn't even read.
Okay.
Goes to jail,
learns how to read,
becomes a lawyer,
finds a hole in his fucking in his three strikes thing and gets out.
So while he's in jail,
some dude is calling himself Rick Ross and he's a big fat guy who used to be a
corrections officer.
No Way.
A corrections officer is pretending that he was this big time drug dealer,
Rick Ross.
So now Rick Ross gets out of jail and he's trying to sue them.
He's trying,
but he's like going to battle.
They're going to have the record.
Companies are going to battle with him over his own real name.
That's awesome.
It's insane.
This is a movie Tait Fletcher.
This is not a real world.
This is not of this world is not real.
Just because you can touch it and move it around as a mother fucker's fake this,
this is,
there's no way that's possible in 2012 is no way that should be possible.
Some guy could,
it could be a corrections officer.
I get that.
He's like that.
Every one of his raps.
Is there a wrap that he has that's not about shooting somebody or having a pound
of blow?
Yeah,
it's all about hustling.
He's,
but how about the fact that he's got Rick Ross tattooed on his fingers?
He's get Rick Ross Thompson that closely,
dude,
he's got another man's name tattooed on his fingers and that other man is that a
jail now because he's smart.
None of the guys are real bad mother fucker.
He's not some fake fat guy who knows how to make shit rhyme.
That's awesome.
Wow.
It's a crazy story,
man.
It's really weird story.
How long did you spend with them?
We did two podcasts with him and he came back and the,
the dude's we could do a hundred more man.
They got some stories.
Yeah.
And he's still fighting it in court.
Very nice guy,
man.
He's got money.
No,
no,
no.
He's barely getting by.
But he's a,
I mean he's,
I'm sure,
I mean,
I guess he could make money doing like interviews or doing like,
um,
uh,
seminars or something like that.
But I think he's trying to do it more for,
for like real benefit.
Man.
He's like doing a lot of different speeches for young kids and telling his story
and trying to offer inspiration because the dude went to jail.
He didn't even know how to read.
He was a tennis player,
like a really bad ass tennis player and in learning how to play tennis,
the Williams,
his uncle,
he was a really good tennis player,
but he couldn't read so it couldn't go to college.
So it's like you would never go get a screen play.
So I'm sure they must have something going on.
We actually talked to him about,
we said too short how to play it
too short.
Looks just like him.
I'm telling you,
he's taller than too short,
but he has two shorts face.
It's kind of crazy.
Or maybe Denzel Washington could play him.
They can fucking play anybody.
Right.
He's bad ass man.
You're doing it.
You did a movie with them.
Yeah.
It just got off.
What is it?
It's called two guns.
Tim,
him and Mark Wahlberg and uh,
we're,
our crew is all navy seals and then we split from Walberg.
He was one of our crew.
And then we go to kill them and the movie's US hunting them basically.
What do you,
what do you feel like when,
if you are real navy seal and you saw these crazy like missing an action type
movies and shit,
when people do ridiculous stuff,
what the fuck does it like crazy dude on films is that all those guys,
the producers and directors,
they're like,
we need this to look real.
We need this.
We want it to be authentic and tell it's the day to shoot it.
And then they're like,
okay,
we're going to flip the car over 16 times and you're just going to,
uh,
you're going to push it off and you'll just push out and roll something like
that.
It's ridiculous,
you know?
And um,
there's a lot of that,
that none of it matters.
It's all a suspension of belief,
you know?
Yeah.
There's a certain amount of that you do in a movie though.
And I lose level 10.
I could never get to level 10 of you move it.
You know what though,
dude is like,
you look at uh,
American kickbox or something,
and as a MMA fighter you look at that and you're still like awesome.
And he's dipping his fucking gauze and not in glass and shit.
You're like,
yeah,
right.
But it's never going to kick.
I don't think it was that just called kickboxer.
Yeah,
just the John Claude van Damme.
Yeah.
I think when you get to a certain,
uh,
you,
you know,
we have to suspend disbelief like that,
you'd never going to hit like that godfather level.
Right.
You know,
when you see like the Godfather and you watch that movie go,
God damn,
they nailed that motherfucker.
The way they choke that dude in the restaurant,
the murders looked real.
Everything.
There was no sensationalizing do's is exactly as much gore as you would see if
you were in the periphery.
You felt like you were in the experience.
They weren't bullshitting you at all.
So by the time you,
when you get out of that movie,
like,
Whoa,
same things like apocalypse now forever.
Those movies hold up,
or the deer hunter,
perfect example.
Perfect example.
What a crazy ass movie that was,
and they had to take the deer with one shot.
That was their thing.
Well,
they're all getting tortured with the,
with the,
uh,
Alicia over that and all that.
Oh my God,
me,
the Russian roulette scene with Christopher Walken,
that is one of the most intense scenes in any movie of a,
of any era.
Even today,
if that movie came out today,
it would a hundred percent hold up.
Like maybe a little bit of the music was probably a little coin in this.
What's out there today that doesn't even have you seen expendables to no,
it's a nine millimeter shooting in the head,
in your head vaporizers.
It's like that kind of like,
Oh,
kill bill.
And you're like,
why are we doing that right now?
Like,
how about we don't do that?
See,
I'm a hypocrite though,
because I like,
like Avengers type shit.
I like superhero type shit,
but I know it's bullshit.
You know?
It's like,
I like that too,
but I don't like this miss you.
Marshy like halfway shit when you pretended it to real movie.
But some nonsense happens.
How come this Duke to beat everybody up so easy like what's going on there?
You know these guys,
you're making these guys look like skilled fighters and this guy is just taking,
I'm going to see Batman.
No mass.
Yeah,
I was going to see it.
But that whole uh,
Colorado shooting thing kind of scared me.
No,
no,
no.
Fuck.
Well definitely if I was there and he's scared,
but uh,
don't,
I don't think I could watch it without thinking what those people were thinking.
I didn't think of those people at all.
I'm going to,
I'm ready to get it on blue ray and wear my shoes in bed just in case you gotta
run.
Yeah.
You felt the same way,
right?
Like I just,
I,
you know,
I barely go to the movies so
I dunno.
I haven't had a hurt the box office to that.
She had had to,
it had to it,
that's a terrible thing to think of.
Why would you think that is all they would think of?
But it also highlighted how you could have 300 million people living together.
But it's so rare that something like this pops off.
To me it was like,
it was,
it was disgusting,
horrible,
sad event.
But when I really analyze the facts,
I was like,
man,
we get along way better than people give us credit for.
True.
Everybody's armed,
everybody's hammered drunk or what,
you know what I mean?
It's like there's all that shit going on,
there's all these variables and people are vying for the same job.
People aren't doing very well and still,
you know,
people aren't getting axed everyday.
It's not like it was back in the 90s in la where there's shootings on the
freeway and Shit,
you know?
Yeah.
Uh,
I think it mean even back in the night,
I think it's like we have more access to the,
to the news now.
Like from everywhere.
Anything that's bad from anywhere we get real quick.
So we get a real distorted perception of what interacting with human beings is
like.
Cause the,
the model that we're dealing with is 300 million people,
which is just crazy that you would take individual episodes out of that and try
to apply it to like what the world is actually like because there's just too
many.
The numbers are just to like,
no,
people don't really know what the fuck 300 million is,
but you couldn't see it.
300 million is if you got everybody in front of you just in this country that
lived there would literally be,
you could stand on top of like a mountain and you would see nothing but people
till the horizon.
Like that's an insane amount of people and they're making some shit choices and
they're coming over to your house and they're fucking putting some drugs on
aluminum foil and lighten it up in front of you.
And you're like,
what the fuck are yous killing?
Disrespectful.
Lighten up fucking crystal meth and funding with Nice tits.
Even less respectful.
Well,
it's just like,
whoa,
what kind of craziness are you one in here?
What do you think about all that?
Like now we don't have as much outward violence like that.
But you look at right now what's happening and it seems like it started like it
seems like prison is a template for shit and I'm just like,
we're going make sure blacks,
Mexicans,
white people don't get along and we're going to control the population that way.
And you look now like 2030 40 years later,
like down the road.
And even now we'd like you within the Republican Party or like people are hating
like there's more division.
The more divisions that are created,
the more easily controlled people are.
You know what,
man?
I think that's just human nature.
I think people are insecure and they're always going to hate on the other team.
It's so,
it's like part of our DNA.
It's part of our DNA to look at Mexicans and go,
oh,
that's not me.
And look at a,
you know,
a white guy looks exactly like,
you're like,
that's my guy.
And look at a black eye.
Like,
Ooh,
I can't trust him.
It's like that's another team.
Like they,
it's hard out there.
And the best way to get through this shit is we form groups and we have loyal
mother fuckers that are down with us.
Fuck everybody else.
Right.
And that's what people sort of,
they,
they gravitate towards that.
And when you gravitates towards that,
it's like,
it's,
you're always going to have conflict.
But it's like where there's a lack of enlightenment.
Is that a broken construct?
I think there's a lot of people capitalizing on human nature and that's what
they're doing and making a fuck load of money off of prisons and they're making
a fuck load of money off of making sure that these areas are not rehabilitated.
So they have a steady supply of people to keep that.
I think that's absolutely true.
Maria mine,
his brother does like big,
like if you've got $20 million,
he'll do your mutual funds and set up your portfolio and all that shit.
And I ask him what were,
where's all the real money going?
Where,
where people really look into put,
put Lou and he says in the correction system in prisons,
Jeez.
And those are the,
those are the futures.
That's fucking kind of,
it's a little crazy,
but it makes sense.
Then also you look,
we're going to go to war with the Mexican immigrants that are coming in and
we're going to need to house them now.
And so we're putting like ever since the 90s when they started doing privatized
prisons,
that became a a cash cow for people.
And so every bad,
so we need longer sentences,
pot.
We're never really going to get really legal because most of those fucking
people that are in these victimless crimes or are in prison for drugs like that
shit that doesn't it.
And when you find out that corrections officers have unions and the unions lobby
to keep thinking it's crazy
or that Ikea gets their furniture made by guys that are making 12 cents a day,
you know what I mean?
That's slavery.
If that's not slavery,
you tell me what it is.
Oh,
this guy fucked ups and now he has to be a slave.
It's not that you trying to protect society from an rehabilitate and was like,
nope,
now you work for pennies now your work.
I mean it's really nuts.
You know?
Those Foxconn people,
they're riding right now.
There's one of the Foxconn factory.
He's just like a 2000 person riot going on.
They blacked it off from the Chinese version of Twitter.
They've like deleted images.
Like they're,
they're suspending accounts and trying to like delete everyone's uh,
accounts of it because they can get into the internet and they can delete shit
in China.
They can like just delete your websites,
which basically they can do here too.
Now the government has already done that.
They're trying taking those kinds of things.
Yeah.
They want to have more and more power to be able to do that.
But in China,
what they're doing right now,
it's,
it's stopping descent because there's a gigantic,
this is the reason why this shit is dangerous in America and we,
for whatever reason,
we accept it and we think it's okay.
It's no big deal.
Hey,
if you're not putting anything bad on the internet,
shouldn't worry about it.
But that's,
that's what's ridiculous is when people have power over you,
they fucking almost always abused it.
If you go back to the Stanford prison studies and they did it with college
students,
they had college students pretend to be prisoners and prison guards,
people with power abuse.
It's inside of like a day.
It's on a day like no time.
And these are just college students in a simulation.
Yep.
And that has just w w you can't have it that way.
You can't have people to be able to take down the internet.
The Internet has to stay free because if it doesn't stay free,
then you're not going to be able to squash you.
You're,
you're,
you're not going to be able to get rid of really corrupt governments.
Like the reason why all these people in Egypt,
all these people in other parts of the world that they,
they're having these rallies against their corrupt government is because they're
able to communicate with each other.
So we're assuming that our people that are in power are always going to be fair
and always going to be just,
and always going to be loyal to the good of the American people.
But we've already seen through Nixon.
We've already seen through the evidence of shit that was past the past.
That's not the case
in Iran.
The only way that they were able to mobilize the resistance there was through
Twitter.
They blacked out everything else and that's the only thing that was free and
clear for them.
And then that went on to Spain and the Indignados that started off the
revolution there to Syria right now in the news right now today,
and then he marks now what happened with occupy Wall Street.
They've fucking got a couple of hundred people they arrested.
Even though if you listen to mainstream media,
they say,
Nah,
that shit's dead.
It's like,
well how come you arrest 200 fucking citizens that just wanted to go and talk
about how come the banks are fucking us?
The real,
the,
the real situation has that this system is broken and they're just trying to
like glute keep like taping it together as it's a fallen apart until like
couldn't tape and it's wrong.
Noma got it.
We got him.
Got It.
We got do in order to have it,
we're going to have to take some rights away to keep this fucking thing up.
And the glue,
the top of it up there,
it's,
you know,
it's a broken ass system and some mathematical genius first and foremost has to
come up with some way of distributing,
uh,
like to distributing taxes and a way of figuring out what money really is based
on and what money really is to say have something,
it has to be based on something.
It has to be some sort of resources,
whether it's oil and gas or coal or wood or money has to be based on something.
It has to equal x amount of something because right now it's just chaos.
And because of the fact that it's just chaos,
it's like people are manipulating it and do not kinds of wacky shit with it.
And you,
you can,
you can move things up and down and move them all around.
And the idea of stocks and dividends and banking,
there's a whole economy based on gambling that other businesses are going to
fail shitty.
It's insane.
It doesn't even make any sense.
Well,
it's like I listen to the grand home,
uh,
who was the governor of Michigan and she was talking about states and incentives
and people have so much surplus money to bring in Dell computers or whoever to
start businesses.
So we can have 5,000 new jobs in Michigan,
whatever the deal is.
She says,
but that whole construct is built and based upon that Ohio doesn't do well then
it's all built on taking.
And Texas has really great incentives so they get a lot of like,
and so that's a for if for national construct that's fucking horrible.
We've got to have states doing.
And then if you look globally,
it's like I need Mexico and Cuba to do poorly for United States.
Like it's like that whole consciousness has to shift in a way.
Yeah.
Well we got to figure out a way,
first of all to the idea that there's,
this is going to sound really crazy,
but we can't have countries.
It doesn't make any sense.
You can't say that just because you were born on this patch of dirt.
You can't make your way over here where there's opportunity because isn't that
what being a fucking human and a society developing is all about developing
society is a society that wants everyone to have an opportunity to do better.
Everyone.
It doesn't just mean these.
The people that were lucky enough to be born in California.
What about the people that are born in South America?
They should be able to come here and it's going to fuck things up for a while,
but will balance out eventually and the benefit would be the entire human race
if it's handled by brilliant people,
if it's handled by true humanitarians,
if it's handled wisdom,
true altruism.
If the people at the top of the of government really we're explaining to
everyone that we
have to think about the future of the human race and in order for the human race
to grow at the top,
it has to also grow at the bottom.
It can't have a rotten foundation.
And that's essentially when you deal with these,
these parts of the city where there's no getting out,
man,
you're fucked.
Like this Rick Ross Story.
It's 28 years old.
Can't fucking read.
You know,
like how did he get through high school?
What happened is poor fucking guy that we got that that rotten system has to
somehow or another be fixed.
The thing you're talking about too,
there's not,
when you say it'll be fucked up for a while,
it's like there's not like an epic downside.
It's like everybody will be fed,
clothed and taken care of,
but where we're going now that's not fucking happening and those divisions are
getting greater and greater and it's like at the same time,
if there's no separation between you and me,
the dude in India or the fucking pop that he's fucking trying to make with his
hands that can,
we're all the same shit.
Like those divisions hurt me.
Yeah.
They definitely hurt us in the air.
Could be reconstruction money just like this reconstruction money in Iraq,
this reconstruction money and Iraq.
They could make money by,
first of all,
hiring excellent counselors.
They could fucking set up businesses or these kids can be trained in like trades
and shit where you can set them up where they,
they always have a place to sleep.
So nobody has ever threatened their life,
has never threatened that.
Never scared.
Like if you,
if you can't go to your neighborhood,
you can't come home.
Like you can come here.
This mother Fucker is guarded 24 hours a day.
We have,
you know,
armed cops here,
we have plenty of food come on in and is no shame in this and we're just going
to have to ask you to contribute a little bit.
You come in here and use a bed,
maybe you to wash a couple of dishes or maybe you've got to put some stuff away
or May,
you know,
real simple.
Now you don't have to work all day.
Maybe put in 20 you know what I mean?
Like have it set up so somebody gets a value for what they do and then have
people who can teach them shit cause that's the same shit with the welfare
system is that you give it to them.
Nobody values that shit it.
And so,
so they don't feel that merited.
They feel lower self esteem that,
you know what I mean?
The whole shit cycles.
But what you're talking about is if people that were in power had a desire to do
that.
Right now you can look in somebody's ass in prison and,
and it's the richest drug community ever.
And they talk about we don't want drugs in the early,
you don't cause at how are they or you're thriving off of it looking at people's
and that mom's scared by putting more public money into fucking the DEA.
Yeah,
you,
it's,
it's a weird situation.
It's like,
it's totally a logical,
like if you look at the way human beings have set up our society and the way we
treat like impoverished neighborhoods and the way we deal with ridiculous laws
and none,
you know,
laws of victimless crimes where people like rot away in jail for the dozens of
pages upon pages of,
of cases,
even recently of people going to jail for long stretches under questionable
circumstances.
And this is this stories where people were set up by,
by government agents.
That's the other thing you have to think about is like when you're uh,
working for the DEA or you're working for the FBI,
like you've got to arrest people,
you got a bus crime,
you got to actually get things done.
I have one of the ways to get things done.
It's a talk someone into doing some crime,
talk a bit of doing some crime and then arrest them.
And that's not illegal.
And that's crazy because you can talk people into sucking your Dick.
You can talk people that are jumping in front of trains,
you could talk a whole bunch of people to,
into killing themselves because the fucking comments coming and there's a UFO
behind it.
You can talk people in anything.
You can't tell me that a smart cop who makes a living being an undercover agent.
So that means a person who thrives under pressure is really good at lying and
manipulating people.
Really good at lying and manipulating people enough so that he can hang around
with the enemy and they think he's one of them.
You told me this guy can't talk someone and doing some shit,
they would never do.
Of course he can.
So he's essentially creating crime and then arresting people for doing that
crime that's been paid people to keep doing crime.
And when I was a kid,
I worked for this guy and uh,
and he maybe he crossed a couple state lines or something.
He ended up doing about nine years behind it.
But the way he got set up and pinched was because his cousin worked for the
police and they'd give him below and they,
and they would fucking go and say,
just stay in the game.
Just stay in.
And so there's a bunch of dudes that are just pieces of shit that are like,
they're like,
stay in the game,
stay in the game and you know,
so he's selling dope,
they know that he's doing all kinds of crime,
but he's going,
hey Lyle,
I need to get two keys from you.
And then he's like,
yeah,
come on over.
And he comes over and next thing there's a,
there's a door kicker in and,
and so it's like that shit happened.
Like,
and that's just little shit that I know from my personal life from fucking 20
years ago.
But that's what's really going on around big level.
That's like come on and people would not want to believe that that is the case.
But that's what happened with Whitey Bulger when I was a kid and I lived in
Boston.
Whitey Bulger was the scariest guy in Boston.
He was the number one gangster in Boston.
You're talking about a guy who won the lottery twice.
Irish crime boss.
He won the lottery twice.
I mean if that's not just ruthless.
Yeah.
That mother fucker won the lottery twice.
I mean,
he was just a straight criminal.
Okay.
Killed a bunch of people and turns out he was working for the FBI the whole
time.
So the FBI would give him information,
he would kill people.
The FBI would,
okay,
so that's like a,
the departed.
Yeah,
exactly.
Exactly.
Based on him,
based on race.
Based on what you Bolger yeah,
they just arrested him like in Santa Monica a little while ago,
a year and had a couple of hundred grand in the,
in the,
in a little apartment up there.
Yup.
And they were looking for that guy forever,
man.
They were looking for him for la.
He was living in modest man just trying to standard PBL and Santa Monica.
Yeah.
Him and his old lady,
they got pinched up there though.
Fuck.
He thought people wouldn't recognize him like you and they actually got them
because someone recognized the girl really recognize his girlfriend.
They all these photos of his girlfriend and they put his photos of his
girlfriend everywhere and someone in the neighborhood recognize the girlfriend
from some TV show.
I don't know why.
I guess he couldn't get out of the country.
Huh?
Well,
I don't know.
I guess he was fighting with the chick to like screaming and yelling and that's
like,
it would turn on to them.
You know,
there was a,
some,
some fucking,
uh,
a violent altercation,
a lot of yelling and so that,
that guy,
people that tune into them.
And then the lady recognized her,
I think this,
I might be butchering the story,
but the bottom line is that guy was a fucking undercover agent for the FBI as
well as the number one crime figure in Boston.
That's crazy.
And not just some crime,
but murder,
setting up likes,
massacres.
How were those FBI guys not in jail?
I know.
How are they not in jail if they're still alive?
So they not in Jay.
How's it not an investigation?
Those dudes who was it the guy right after,
uh,
after uh,
the Oklahoma City bombing and that Guy Tim Mcveigh.
Yeah.
But the guy that kept,
uh,
who was like a white separatist or something up in the mountains.
Oh,
Ruby Ridge.
Yeah.
I think that's before.
That wasn't as right after on the heels when they'd just want to vilify all the
malicious oh yeah.
I'm,
I'm thinking,
I'm thinking it was different,
but um,
cause I think Ruby Ridge was like,
yeah,
it was from 92.
Was that,
yeah,
the um,
Ruby,
which was [inaudible] 92 and Oklahoma City was 90.
Man,
I think it was 93 or four,
because I think I was living here.
When was the Oklahoma Obama.
Obama.
It looks like this.
Uh,
the,
the real,
uh,
um,
oh,
I'm sorry.
Here in Oklahoma City bombing,
it was Ruby Ridge and killed that guy.
Randy Weaver.
Was it,
and they killed him and his kids.
Yeah.
Ruby Ridge was later.
You know,
there's a lot of fucking conspiracy with the Oklahoma City bombing.
There's all these news reports.
It says the FBI pulled out,
um,
many bombs,
more than one,
multiple bombs from the building that hadn't exploded.
And a,
if you look at the damage that's done to the building,
apparently demolitions experts say that the building blew out.
It didn't blow in.
So if there,
you're saying that a car was parked that did that [inaudible] they're saying no.
The rear,
the demolitions experts are saying,
no,
this is something that blew out,
is it was,
it was detonated from the inside and it blew outward.
And so there's a lot of people that think that there must have been something
more than just Timothy Mcveigh's efforts and weren't all the agents cleared out
the kids in daycare or something like that and that's it.
The agents were cleared out,
they knew about something in advance they were evacuated and that which is
really just sick when you just think about that.
Like why didn't you evacuate the whole building?
Like well what the fuck is going on in collateral damage.
Cause they also had to make sure that it actually happened.
If the guys pulls up in his truck and everyone's out of the building,
you know in his firetrucks everywhere,
he's like,
Oh fuck this job and leaves.
So I don't know,
that's speculation.
But it was weird that Timothy move Vagos to his grave without ever making a
statement ever.
Yeah.
But like well the thing is that they,
the fertilizer bomb experts,
I guess there are actually are those,
they say that this is not,
this is not indicative of the damage that one of those things is capable of
doing.
This is not that much pop like this is,
this is some crazy shit.
Like if you look at the building,
half the building's missing.
It's like the whole front,
it just blew out.
You know what I mean?
It's like if you're in a pickup truck or whatever you need for,
for like if you have gunpowder and he put it in your palm and you light it,
poof it poofs but if you wrap that fucker and tin foil boom,
like,
or a pipe bomb.
Like if you ever fuck with explosives,
it's like you need it wrapped in a certain way for it to go.
It's not just going to be sitting in a truck and have a huge mag magnanimous
kind of explosion or you had an explosive affects her.
I've gotten to that way a little bit just because of my work lately.
Like I,
I've been going like,
how has this bomb wrap?
How close can I get to that?
Like on a vendors that we had a lot of bombs going off down the middle of the
street.
Right.
And so you had to get like within a certain distance of it.
But then I found out about wraps and how they were,
um,
how they really changed the nature of the explosion.
And I blew a couple of things up when I was a kid,
but I didn't really know much about it.
But that's if that's what you're getting at Brian now,
I'd just like to,
you look like an explosive expert.
How you do
some,
it's a weird thing man.
It seems like every event that happens,
no matter what it is,
has a gang of conspiracy theories.
What do you think about the Batman thing?
Like when they're like,
that kid's a broke college student,
how do you get 30 grand worth of fucking a student loans,
student loans that cuts that one,
right?
Yeah.
Um,
so government funded,
you're saying that you're saying it is government?
Well,
his therapist was not surprised that that kid was apparently exhibiting some
very troublesome issues.
I'm not buying the idea that you could program someone to do that without
spending all fuck load of time with them.
And I've heard that this kid was involved in something,
you know,
is in an area that had something,
but I,
he was a fucking a phd student.
Right.
Positing is it going to get a doctorate?
Yeah.
This is,
I,
this is a really brilliant kid who has worked really hard about the same age as
the cause brokens.
Well,
those kids were,
a lot of that was linked to antidepressants,
you know,
so both in Colorado.
Yeah,
it's true.
There's a lot of links here.
You know what that Christine's in Colorado.
Yeah.
There's a little of that.
A lot of wackiness.
Yeah,
it's true.
There's a lot of calories,
especially Colorado Springs.
Yup.
But there's also like not that much air.
Maybe that's,
sorry.
Well,
my wife
was pregnant up there,
man.
It was fucking hard to watch her man.
Just like she had the flu.
And then when she came back,
we moved back to California.
Boom.
Instantly she was 50% better.
Yup.
Yeah.
You're not really supposed to live with the EHRs,
that thing,
man.
And having a fucking baby man.
That'd be crazy.
Yeah.
It's pretty fucking crazy.
Imagine carrying that around the whole thing that women go through.
I think you make giving birth well that too.
I said you think you'd like to give birth?
I think it'd be sweet,
easy parts.
Could you imagine having it like a human commodity?
It's insane.
I've
seen it happen twice.
It's the strangest thing ever,
man.
It was the strangest thing ever.
But uh,
they,
they have a lot of premature births in Colorado because that era,
it's,
I think it's like one,
the number one places in the country where that's premature births because
there's no fucking air up there.
I hear the actresses do it in Hollywood a lot so that they don't get stretched
out to get them a month or two before they're ready to pop.
Was sought him out.
Who the fuck does that?
Explosive.
What?
Did he know?
No,
ray is he,
that is so crazy.
Heat that body viable.
Oh,
well some girls do get like really bad stretch marks.
It's just genetics.
Some girls don't get nothing.
It's weird.
I was like,
some girls,
they have one baby and you're done son.
It's,
and they have him young.
Yeah.
That can happen to do it in the way we just got back from Louisiana.
Everybody's got a baby,
but everybody looks like they're 12 years old anyway.
It's like you're in 98% humidity all the fucking time.
It's like you're living in in water almost like in an aquarium and you're like,
it's just like a couple of degrees off of the air just turning to water.
It's like really good for your skin.
Right?
Fucking crazy.
He goes,
great.
If my joints felt great,
like really everything my show,
I got fucked shoulders and everything.
I felt good.
I worked out every day and everyone felt awesome.
Wow.
Maybe we should move to Louisiana desk.
Why Louisiana?
You down?
No,
I don't think you want a new Orleans.
You don't even like Marnie ground,
hurricane,
hurricane zombies out loud guys.
Just murdering people and they got a thing they call misdemeanor murder
side of,
uh,
outside of,
um,
Louie of um,
Louisiana or in the,
in Louisiana,
outside of New Orleans.
It's a,
they have so many people in jail that if they don't officially like try you for
something,
if they don't officially charge you with something and that within 30 days they
have to release you.
So guys get arrested for murder and they just can't get to them so they can
just,
they just let them out because there's so many motherfuckers in jail and so once
they get used to popping people,
um,
I might have butchered that,
that thing,
but I know that there is a term called misdemeanor murder.
I might have butchered whatever the,
the actual reason they let him out so quickly.
Yes,
but it's not,
they don't get charged.
They just,
this is crazy.
It's crazy.
This w there was a lot of reports of like really crazy shit going down in the
post.
They,
the days post Katrina like bet the cops were just fucking Jack and people
everywhere.
Just taking people out.
You know,
that there was all sorts of breaking in and looting and lot
a lot of goods.
Imagine you drive around the like Bourbon street drive around the French quarter
and it's like,
it's kind of hazy.
You expect Jack The ripper to come out from around the corner.
Like that's where that motherfucker lives.
Like anybody could get got there at any time.
It feels like you should have to have a passport to go to New Orleans.
Beautiful.
The other time everybody's so fucking sweet,
their co honey,
how you doing?
It's like you can't walk down,
everybody's going to smile at you,
ask you how you're doing and they're going to give a fuck.
They're going to be genuine.
It's crazy friendly,
too.
Great.
Um,
a limo driver,
he was the shit,
this guy who was really cool as fuck man.
And he took us around New Orleans and from New Orleans and he was telling us
stories about like the one time it moved out of New Orleans and uh,
came out of store and he's sitting there drinking a beer and uh,
the cop cop pulled up and the cops like,
you want to tell us what you're doing?
Oh yeah,
man.
I'm just a friend's going to meet me.
I'm just having a beer and he goes,
are you really so fucking stupid that you're drinking his beer in front of me?
Like he got,
he kept drinking it and he's like,
what the fuck is wrong?
Like what's wrong?
He goes,
he goes,
where are you from?
And the guy goes,
New Orleans,
and he goes,
okay,
let me tell you the way they do things down there.
It's not like anywhere in the world.
You can't just,
I,
I'm telling you this because I know that you don't know because you're from New
Orleans and I've talked to people from New Orleans before.
I just got to tell you,
you're not allowed to drink in public.
Like that's alien to them.
Alien.
You could drink everywhere in New Orleans,
but really that's the way it should be,
man.
You should be able to drink anywhere.
You should be able to drink anywhere you want.
You just,
you have to have another house somewhere.
You have to have a house in a fucking dude.
Katie was,
however,
an idea about what life is like anywhere else and you just,
it's fucking locked down Bourbon Street.
I'm like,
did they just get everybody fucked up at the Walmart and put them in too tight
clothes and then get a party bus and dump them all off here?
Like,
yeah,
it's fucking nutty.
It's weird.
Yeah.
Guy gave me a laser pointer and he goes,
man,
I want you to have this.
I go,
what is is the laser pointer?
uh,
why?
Why go,
why you want me to have a manned sub?
Thank you.
Cool Dude.
I want you to have my laser pointer.
Okay,
thanks man.
He just had to give me something.
We wanted to give me something,
man.
I'll fucking move.
You know true.
Here's your laser point of has a awesome,
it's like this is so bizarre.
A laser pointer and everywhere you go it's like Strip club bars,
strip club bar
called livestream show,
live sex show advertised in the street.
Come on in.
Watch people.
Fuck.
I didn't have the heart to go in and I didn't.
I wanted to,
I want it to like 4% of me and I'm like,
I just can't
tell you what I did.
It was a beautiful place to do.
Standup comedy.
That is a beautiful place to do stand up comedy.
I might have to type my next special after I released the Atlanta one,
I might have to take my next one,
do it early in the day.
They'll get too fucked up.
Nah Man,
I had a regular nighttime show.
It was great.
You know,
every weekend they have a huge party.
Like they have a red,
like a red dress run.
Everybody throws on a red dress and fucking runs like a fucking half mile.
But it's like,
it's like a moving cocktail party basically happens in the morning and goes all
the way down tonight.
Or they had a running of the bulls that I did.
It was awesome.
I put some videos on Facebook,
but it was like all of these roller derby girls from surrounding states will
come there.
They'll all put on red.
Yeah,
red.
And they'll put horns on their helmets and shit and they'll have wiffle ball
bats and there'll be the bowls of Pamplona and there'll be beating
motherfuckers.
Everybody's dressed in white.
I had on a Tutu.
It was awesome
to sue.
So funny.
That's crazy.
And this theme for a party there,
man,
there's,
I was in the strip bar and there's a fucking Mexican chick comes up and we're
talking and she's again from Tucson originally,
blah,
blah.
Cool,
cool,
cool.
It's just like everybody's twisted a little bit there.
And she goes,
Hey,
I'm going to this,
uh,
you want to come with me this weekend?
I'm going to go to this music festival.
My best friend's band he's playing in.
I said,
oh,
awesome.
She's like,
what kind of music do you like?
I'm like,
you know,
whatever.
And like,
usually with strippers it's like ACDC or little Wayne.
It's like,
what?
Like something in that genre is what you're thinking.
I,
you know.
And she's like,
yeah,
it's a Neo Nazi punk show.
And I said,
excuse me?
She's like a Neo Nazi punk show and like your best friend's band.
And she's like,
yeah,
and you're Mexican.
I'm like,
I'm too confused and there no way I wouldn't get killed.
They're out here one conversation and then it be just like a boot party on me.
Like there'd be 15 little skinny dudes with fucking steel toed boots kicking my
face.
Then
it's like the,
these are confused folks.
Oh,
that's hilarious.
Yeah.
There's a lot of that going on as country too.
If they said that something like 50% of the country believes in the biblical
tale of creation and that the earth is less than 10,000 years old,
50%.
I don't know how they estimate that,
but seems low.
They can't point to where a state has either.
The shores,
Florida,
they're like,
I don't know.
Well,
if I didn't fly around a lot of mine,
I know.
You know,
I can't explain to you where the fucks out the code is.
He asked me to pinpoint that motherfucker gonna Learn North Dakota.
Yeah.
But I wouldn't find that fucker either.
I don't know where that shit is.
You know?
I barely know where Ohio is and I love Ohio,
but like places that I don't go to shit,
I don't know where the fuck they are.
You know?
Where's Wyoming?
Where the fucking north.
Yeah,
but try to find it.
I'm the same way.
There's only a few places everywhere.
This places that I've never been like Wyoming's one of 'em Montana's another
one.
No,
never.
I don't know where the fuck they iron man.
I'll go there,
but I don't want to stay there very fucking long.
It seems desolate.
Montana's bu I'm going hunting in Montana over for what?
Me and Brian Cowen.
We're going hunting for deer with this guy.
Steve Rinella.
He's the author of this show,
the meat eater,
and uh,
I've been wanting to go honey forever.
I've been saying I want to do it for years,
to the point where people are getting annoyed at me for saying it.
But it's true.
I,
I've,
I like,
I eat meat.
I should be responsible for killing at least one animal that I eat.
You know,
you'd never killed an animal.
No.
Just fish.
Never killed an animal.
Yeah,
we grew up.
That's all.
Yeah,
that's all we did.
Like just murdering.
Yeah.
Poppy isn't shit that my first kill was a doberman.
You killed it.
Everybody in Michigan,
we
grew up hunting deer shooting deer,
and there's so many.
I mean,
fuck,
I've got friends that we would stop straight hillbillies,
man,
and they'd stop on the side of the road because there's deer that get hit by
cars all the time.
Daddy killing people,
they'll jump out of the guts,
aren't exploded.
They'll go,
got them,
take out their heart tenderloins and then bounce.
Yeah.
That's what a lot of people do.
Crazy.
They found a source,
Steve Vanilla Guy,
and they want to,
on one of his shows,
they found a good deer that was shot and killed and the only thing that was
taken was the backstraps.
That's it.
Yeah.
They just took the backstraps and left the rest of the body.
I'm like,
wow,
that's kind of fucking crazy.
That's part of the deer deal,
but that's really ruthless.
That's fucked up.
You know,
just drag it to a bunch of Xapi,
Lazy Bitch,
you know,
venison sausage is delicious,
dude.
The whole thing is rad that I would take that shit like right when I shoot a
deer,
just because the people that I'd hunt with,
if you left it there like you didn't drag it all the way back to camp.
Hang it up,
scan it and all that.
Yet they'd go and steal your heart and backstraps they'd steal all the
tenderloins.
They'd still have all the best part,
all the best cuts of the meat.
Really?
Yeah.
Wow.
Route bitches.
Yeah.
Apparently that's a lot of,
it's common that people find the idea that someone shot but couldn't find,
you know,
cause a lot of times you find them the blood trails get out so people will like
put their own tag on it and pretend they do it.
I've hit a deer with a 30,
ought six right through the heart,
like in obliterate,
like found it later.
Obliterates the heart one shot runs 250 yards before it,
you know what I mean?
It's like a gut shot deer or something like that.
They go fucking,
and then people go to find them too soon and then they jump them and they'll
just keep running and you'll never did.
You see these photos and Matt Hughes in in Africa and you want an African safari
and killed everything in Africa.
Took pictures of it and put it,
uh,
on,
like Facebook or something like that,
or his website.
And there's just this crazy like,
like Ted Nugent.
Yay.
Yeah.
And there's this,
you know,
people are really mad at him.
It's Kinda,
it's,
it's kind of a funny situation with those,
uh,
killing those animals that you don't eat because although there's something
fucked up about killing an animal,
not eating it,
period.
But then they do donate the money or that they do donate the food rather to
tribes who need it.
And so they,
it,
the food does kill you.
This tiger.
That's true.
That's a good point.
You know what I mean?
Well then he didn't shoot,
shoot any tigers.
He only shot like antelopes and stuff like that.
Zebra.
Yeah.
Waste son shutters.
He froze.
That's Kinda kinda crazy.
But here's,
but here's the other part of it.
Um,
when you,
when you go on these hunts,
which is essentially like hunting in a fucking zoo.
Okay.
It's like a wildlife preserve.
When you go on these hunts,
the money goes to conservation.
So it actually helps these animals stay like maintained because otherwise the
poachers,
and there'd be no way to stop all the,
the people from,
you know,
going after animals that they can profit from like rhinos and shit like that.
They were essentially zebra.
They've essentially made rhinos almost extinct.
Like some rhinos are extinct and they've got an extinct in our lifetime.
So this controlled hunting actually keeps a lot of those animals alive.
So it's really ironic.
There's two parts of that though for me.
Like I go,
if you really care about the animals than just give them your fucking money.
You know what I mean?
Like don't some fucking money then Dick head.
Well that's the other thing is that no,
you actually have to kill some of them,
but that's in Michigan.
That's so true.
You get Lyme disease and shit like that.
Like the animals will,
we'll start to disease themselves if they're overpopulated.
And so the DNR goes and they count them and they know what's happening and they
issue so many permits or whatever.
But I don't think that's happening with,
I mean maybe it is,
I
don't know what the conservancy is in Africa,
but you know in places like that,
do you need to kill that many of them?
I think they do.
In certain areas you have to look in.
Unless you have an abundance of cats a year,
you're going to have to have something that controls the population and they
don't want to have an abundance of cats.
Right.
It's dangerous as fuck,
you know?
So in these wildlife preserves,
I'm pretty sure they have to kill a lot of them.
I think they have to do it unless there are fucking around with as lions and
tigers,
Barbara.
Yeah.
Right.
I think we do.
Not Enough.
We've got a sick gene pool.
Yeah,
it's a little bit broken,
but it's,
again,
it's a little bit broken when you think about the fact there's 300 plus million
of us just on this spot.
I think if you look at us worldwide,
I mean it's pretty astonishing like person to person how good we have it here.
I think we are getting,
I mean,
we're moving up,
like when I talked like,
I dunno,
I talk a lot about like,
like lately I'm doing this thing,
this whole life challenge and uh,
what does that,
it's like,
uh,
this thing off this website,
whole life challenge.com and we started it down at a place I work out here
called a crossfit la in Santa Monica a couple,
three years ago,
I guess there's the third year.
And it started with like 40 people doing it and now there's like 9,000 people
doing it.
But it's like a,
it's an accountability program that speaks to nutrition,
mobility,
exercise,
uh,
consciousness.
Um,
what,
what your daily life is like learning something new this week,
kind of a holistic look at your life,
you know,
and,
and just kind tightened in the game of like whatever it is for you.
But,
you know,
part of the thing,
like last week was find out like,
you can't eat anything fried in canola oil.
You can only basically a paleo ish diet,
like no dairy,
no artificial sweeteners and all that kind of stuff.
And,
um,
and so you'd have a lot of conversations if you go out to dinner,
what are your sweet potato fries fried in or whatever.
And you know,
if it's canola oil,
no good duck fat with the awesome grapeseed oil,
awesome.
But uh,
you know,
it's still shit like that.
But like doing it for the last three years and talking to people and I talked to
people about diet and nutrition,
a whole bunch.
People are hip to it now,
whereas before,
like three years ago,
people are like,
mother Fucker,
he's a pain in my ass.
And now people are like,
oh yeah,
this is gluten free and this is easier.
Theresa made was uh,
any kind of wheat or any kind of sugars or no,
no,
we make in the back and Dah,
Dah,
and it's fucking Rad.
The conversations and there does seem to be like a coming together of all these
things,
definitely were being more informed about diet and that's the end.
Gluten free.
Yeah.
That is the internet and 100% of the food and free,
nobody was fucking gluten free just 10 years ago.
Ever heard that shale way that was really rare to hear.
Yep.
Now I can always heats on.
Now my phone is fucking gluten free.
Everywhere you go.
It's weird.
While we're realizing the impact nutrition has on the,
the real realistic,
you know,
uh,
impact it has on your health.
When you see someone who eats healthy and you see someone who doesn't and you
see the difference,
it sits pretty palpable.
There's no getting around it.
And when you,
it yourself and you realize how much better you feel and you start,
and you know,
I,
I do a Kale shakes every morning.
This a thing that I'm doing and now I've got a lot of people doing it because
they listen to the show.
Right?
I can't tell you how many people are running to sir.
Yeah.
Well blender got a Vitamix.
BLENDTEC is supposed to be the shit that's,
they actually blended an iPhone in it.
Yeah,
we check it.
Yeah.
This is a video.
Go,
go Google it because it's ridiculous.
They,
they planned it.
Fuck it.
This blender so bad.
They blended a phone.
I mean it's a blender that can blend other blenders.
It's ridiculous.
And the idea is that it makes these smoothies cause he could cut through,
it cuts through ice like butter Qsen yeah,
loves it.
But he says there's,
there's different kinds of juicers and one like it's an extract shoot up and
then that ruins all the nutrients.
Well it's also hold juicing or something like cold pressing as good.
But I'm not talking about juicing.
I'm talking about making smoothies out of shit.
You need e all of the whole food.
Not just the judge.
Check this,
this blend tech shit up.
You got half a screen so there it goes.
Look at this door.
Check the shit up.
God Damn it Brian.
Brian know cause you got the sound off.
It's not working on this isn't my favorite sticker over here.
Oh yeah.
That gets said a lot.
What is it?
Why is it no volume?
I don't know
which is,
there's no figuring out bitch.
It's weird.
I can't believe you're talking about the the galaxies better than the iPhone.
Huh?
It's better looking to me for free.
For like going on a blind screen for looking at Twitter.
Yeah,
it's all touch screen.
It's beautiful.
I like that to be bigger because I have fucking fingers,
toes.
Exactly.
Me To watch this.
He's going to blend a fucking phone.
This is crazy shit,
man.
He my sis,
he better drink it.
Watch this shit.
Do it,
bitch.
Hit the button.
Stop talking.
Watch this.
Look at that.
He blended a fucking phone into powder.
It was a forest,
so that doesn't make me sad,
but dude,
how incredible is that?
That blender blended a fucking phone in the powder dust.
Look at that shit grows.
That's insane.
Ready to drink and that.
How smart would you be?
Put a little almond.
Oh God,
look at these.
I put that's toxic as fuck dude.
He shouldn't be inhaling air.
Look what that became.
That's insane.
You know what?
That's what the universe is going to do to your iPhone.
Anyway,
that right there is a perfect description.
While we can't find shit from advanced civilizations for 15 20,000 years ago,
it's called the Sahara.
It's called the or of the world,
which is glaciers.
Glaciers are like set up as like if the world was an Etch,
a sketch glaciers of the big shake cause they come
down and they literally smush everything in their place.
When you're dealing with a glacier,
a lot of people think,
oh well it's ice and then it's the isis.
No,
no,
no.
It's a mile high mother fucking mountain of ice that's moving.
And it only moves like a little bit every year,
but it crushes everything in front of.
Think about how big that is.
Mile High.
Well,
North America was covered in a glacier that was a mile high just 10,000 years
ago.
Just 10,000 and Doug about their head see fish that they find skeletons of in
Denver,
which is a mile high already.
And then what is that?
That was under the sea.
Yeah.
What the fuck,
man?
They found,
um,
uh Oh,
a lake,
Ontario.
Like that.
We were a,
we were in Toronto this past weekend.
Right.
And you,
you fly over it like I've,
I've only flown over the Great Lakes couple of times where you really get to
look at it.
You're like,
why am I at the ocean?
Like how am I?
How's this the ocean in the middle of the country?
But it's an ocean.
You can call it a lake all you want.
That fucking thing is huge and that's not even the biggest one.
That was way bigger ones.
There's giant ass lakes and what those are is that used to be glaciers and they
melted.
I mean it's you wrap your head around it.
It's,
it really hurts.
It hurts to think that this spot wasn't even livable one.
When you think about like all the humanity and like how,
how long?
Like we're a blip.
Yeah.
We're nothing like this isn't going to let like so clinging to our house on the
Malibu beach.
This is here forever.
This is a family heirloom.
Like you're,
you're,
you're on the most unstable park where we think it's going or it's going to be
covered in ice.
The whole thing is going to cover again,
the whole world is constantly rolling.
Like that shifts.
They're not the kid that polar bear that came off of a cap and Greenland,
I believe,
and fucking floated to Iceland and took out a troop of fucking boy scouts that
fucking the fucking polar bear.
I'm a fucking ice cap that breaks off.
He's fucked.
He floats.
He's at sea for God knows how long.
And it comes up on some fucking boy scouts and killed like,
I dunno,
12 of them or something like that.
He wiped out crazy.
When did this happen?
I think last year.
Oh,
I just had a friend that did a show in Iceland and they're like this.
that's a beautiful spot.
I'd love to go there.
Yeah.
Iceland's amazing.
But fuck polar bears,
man.
They're tripping.
They come out,
they come out with crocodiles are like great whites,
like a predator.
They come out as a predator.
Do you remember when we,
we,
uh,
we were in Denver and uh,
one of the times we were in Denver,
there was a guy,
I think you were there.
He came down to the show.
He's a local comic and he's also,
forgive me,
I forget,
I forgot the guy's name.
He's Fitzgerald.
Kevin Fitzgerald.
I think that's it.
Uh,
he's also a,
um,
a veterinarian,
so he was talking to us about like a little baby polar bears.
They come out and he said like,
aliens,
like the movie the alien.
They come out of this,
just looking at fucking get you full teeth.
Yeah.
Full teeth
to
Tufts was a fucking just on,
on the La news there was,
it was like a mile out.
It wasn't even that far out off of Santa Monica.
There was like a 30 foot great white.
I see babies a lot.
Oh,
out in the bay,
like audit point Dume and Shit when we go surfing.
But like they're,
they're babies.
They're five feet or eight,
eight feet would be a bigger one,
but a fucking 30 foot.
Great White.
Fuck you.
I know they said that off a Malibu is one of the richest breeding ground where
they drop them off country.
My friend was out,
dude.
He went out to the end of point doom and uh,
why he says a little five foot or it hit us like didn't quite hit his board,
but the tail slap fucking blew them.
Like it's crazy dude too.
That's so scary.
I think of a little one.
It's five pounds,
five feet long.
But like how big that is and how much force it just a pure muscle.
You little one little one Qa just as easy as a pit could kill Ya.
Yup.
Yeah.
That's an amazing,
they're so terrifying,
man.
So scary.
It's like you're out there in the water.
First Time I ever went surfing,
Dude's like
big sea lions come up.
They look like a huge fucking rottweiler.
Just they make noise and shit,
claws and teeth and you're like,
holy fuck.
And then you know,
you see the little porpoises or dolphins or whatever the fuck they are out
there.
And I'm like,
this is fucking Rad.
I'm just sitting there looking at,
he's like,
yeah,
how's it feel to be in the middle of the food chain now?
I'm like,
dude,
if a bunch of fucking salmon came up and just started fucking attacking me,
I would drown.
Like I'm not in the middle.
I'm away at the fucking bottom.
If a bunch of crabs came up and just annoyed me enough to where I fell off this
board,
I would drown in time and they would all eat me.
Like there's no chance I'm in the middle.
You have salmon,
we're trying to jack you and knock you off that board.
You wouldn't be able to stump them.
You'd be done.
A bunch of tuna came up and fucking walk with.
You'd be fat tuners are big man.
And then you think about sea lion.
Yeah.
Cause those are big scary motherfuckers.
Sharks love them.
The Yum.
Yum,
yum.
They'd drop tons of great whites in there all the time.
Oh yeah.
I don't get the surfing thing.
I'm sure it's fantastic.
I might sure if I,
maybe I would surf at that indoor place in Abu Dhabi.
I think they've got like an indoor pool.
I'm sure they do or do buy one of those places.
I think,
you know,
I'm going to play a Taliban guy.
I think you were a little worried about that man.
I like it better not be like this fucking his innocence of Muslims video,
that movie that's out.
You haven't eaten,
you know what's going on.
You don't know.
No.
Oh my God.
Oh fuck.
How bad.
Clint Eastwood fucked up.
Forget him.
The Guy,
I'm a guy,
made a movie with a bunch of white people with black face on playing Muslims and
made it about Muhammad and Muhammad being like a pedophile and it's like really
blasphemous.
So because of that,
there was a tax and American embassies,
uh,
the American embassy in Libya got attack.
That was what it was from on September 11th.
And um,
this,
uh,
one guy who was the American ambassador,
for Olivia was,
was killed in a rocket attack.
And then there's riots all over the world.
And you know,
it was like youtube was cut off by Iran and all these different places online
where you could get this,
they were all cut out.
Like you can't get to it because there's so much to scent and so much revolt.
Because
not only that,
this is,
think about the fact that a hundred and I mean how if you're being conservative,
would you say 150,000 Iraqi civilians died because of the,
uh,
American attack.
That's being really nice.
It's probably way more than that.
Some people estimate it's as much as a million.
So let's say it's 100,000.
Let's be real nice.
They're freaking out about a bad movie,
but they're not freaking out about a hundred thousand people being murdered.
Right?
I mean,
this movie,
all these drone attacks that still crazy Pakistani soldiers.
Yeah.
Oh,
it's the same if you find the video,
Brian show like some of the video of it because it does look almost that bad.
It's,
it's,
and then the other thing is that people think they really,
uh,
the people inclined to conspiracy think that this was all done by the CIA and
that they're trying to get us ready.
Come up number 11,
just because,
exactly.
They're trying to get us ready for this war in,
um,
in Iran.
And the way they can facilitate the get the process moving along is to have
these people revolt.
So they made this movie and apparently the movie was made and then they dub
different lines into the people's mouths.
Like the woman said,
that's not my voice.
And the actress who's playing the woman,
she said,
I never said those things.
They dub those things in afterwards,
which also sounds like something to CIA would do.
Just get you to act in one thing and then make it like fucking ridiculously
inflammatory.
Attach you to it.
Send you out there.
Boom.
You got a movie.
The guy who was the PR person who made the movie is apparently the same guy who
was a burning the Koran.
He was uh,
he was involved in,
uh,
doing some,
some shit with the Quran.
That was this it
is this the movie?
I've never seen it.
Oh my God.
That is the
look at his face.
This can't be real.
Look how brown is faces,
but they didn't brown his neck.
Oh my God.
This is the worst movie that's ever been made
a battleax.
Yo,
look at his beard.
Man that that's no beer.
That's the best beard ever.
That's the best fake beard ever.
Cause they didn't even try.
We just fake beard.
He's mother fuckers have Halloween beards on set the place on fire.
Oh look at his beard,
Dude.
Look at that beer.
Oh my God.
He just Shannon just on,
he had to do it.
Yeah.
He just attack this hot chick with a battleax cause she had a cross on.
She's on my cam.
What country are we in there?
This is an unbelievable,
that was the hottest Arabic checkout oversight.
No,
she wasn't.
Yeah,
she was a Christian though.
That's why she's super hot.
I can't forgive that.
That was the worst movie ever.
Just that scene.
I couldn't even if for the rest of the movie was like,
you know,
team America was more realistic.
Yeah.
That was one of the worst movies all the time with the rest of the movie was
apocalypse now.
That movie's still stopped.
You know?
Did you,
you can't have a scene that bad ever in a movie.
If I saw that in the best movie ever.
If that was like five minutes of American Werewolf in London,
you'd be like,
what?
The five little kid put this in there.
Fuck can a piece of shit movie exists.
There's levels and that the mother Fucker who made that movie is no Stanley
Kubrick.
That's all I'm saying.
The fucking guy had brown face only on his face and not on his neck.
This is a movie tickets.
Fletcher excellence Tait Fletcher.
This shit is not real.
This is a goddamn movie.
We're living in a movie.
We're going to simulation shit like this is just little pieces of evidence
that's like allowing us to wake up and realize this is not real.
It's not real tape.
It's not real.
But this coffee's real good.
Man did this coffee is amazing.
So what?
How do you actually do it?
You said it was like butter.
It's bulletproof your while.
If you want a full explanation,
you got to go to bulletproof exec.com that guy's going to be on the podcast and
a couple of weeks to listen.
Dave Asprey.
Yeah,
you're going to have him here.
Yeah.
He's going to be here on fucking wicked.
I'm such a fan.
Everything that tag is butter or bulletproof or fucking I love the fucking guy.
I'm all over his shit.
He uh,
I dunno.
Like there's him and in conjunction with the dude that wrote the primal diet,
this guy,
Mark Sisson,
who you had fucked.
He should have him on.
He's bad ass.
I would love to.
We had a Robb wolf on.
Rob's a good dude,
Huh?
He worked out at my gym for a while.
He said undisputed when he was in Santa Fe is old lady was finishing up a
program there.
I tried to get me to go from Kale shakes to bacon and eggs.
I tried it for a while.
No,
it doesn't give you the same amount of energy.
It's a totally different experience.
It tastes good.
You throw in a little bit about bulletproof coffee and you'll have that same
energy all day long songs.
Ridiculous.
No,
you got to try to keep drinking it all day.
It's cap.
What's wrong with that?
They crashed the end of the day.
You do not,
you know when you crash,
when it's time to go to sleep and you know what I want to do at that time.
I want to crash.
You just switched to Jack Daniels butter coffee.
What evidence is there?
The coffee actually is bad for you.
Is there any,
I mean I know that if you go too hard it fucks your adrenals to deal right?
Here's the deal,
and you'll talk to Dave a lot about it,
but he talks about the Mycotoxins,
oxy toxins that are all in the blends of coffee and molds attached to coffee
beans all the time.
And so especially if you're getting them from Starbucks or places like that,
like do you ever drink a cup of coffee and then all of a sudden you feel like
kind of down like you because you're poisoning yourself?
Whoa.
You want to be really careful about what I get the coffee from.
So I only drink single origin coffee that you know,
it's comes from a small farm somewhere.
Do you want to really,
you become a geek.
You did have had coffee before and then I get sleepy.
Yeah.
What does that froze because 80 people who have him add also.
You get that though?
No,
I got that shit.
It's the mold that is attached to the coffee.
Dave Asprey talks a lot about it.
Uh,
this has been proven.
I Dunno,
he's like a,
he's a scientist Geek because I saw that on his website was like mole coffee
must be mold free.
All I know is Bryn Napkin.
I uh,
that I changed it and this is what all I do and it fucking,
it's a tremendous differences in 1000%.
So it's called single origin.
If you get a single origin coffee,
which just means that you get it from the same farm.
If you have a blend or a decaf coffee,
your,
your chances of it being mold infested are through the fucking roof.
He's going to know if you go to bulletproof exec,
he's got a,
uh,
an article called why bad coffee makes you weak.
So he elaborates on what talks and talks about how to get stronger from just
drinking coffee.
Well,
if you don't like the taste of bad coffee,
the same reason why you don't like the taste of gasoline,
your body's telling you it's toxic.
Uh,
data on coffee consumption goes back and forth.
Some studies show health benefits or other shows,
negative outcomes.
This might seem confusing,
but the simple reason is this,
bad coffee is good for you.
Oh,
bad coffee is bad for you.
And scientists suck a differentiating types of coffee when they run studies on
coffee.
So their scientific tests that have no science because there's no static model.
So you stay my Trent of ice coffee that I drink every day from Starbucks.
You probably meet yourself as much as it is when you eat gluten.
This is fun.
I've never heard this before and I can't wait to talk to him about this on the
podcast.
This is nuts.
Fascinated dude.
He biohacked his whole body.
He talks about that.
He went up 20 Iq points.
He lost 150 pounds or something.
He was the bio hack,
his body,
an analyst,
a securities analyst,
and in San Fran for a while and he's like,
I just wanted all the different facets of my body.
I thought about how nutrition is affecting me and bringing me towards the
pharmaceutical pharmaceutical answer.
And so he says,
I wanted to get optimized in every aspect of my life.
And he just looked at nutrition and uh,
ed movement.
He even sells one of those machines.
The first time I ever heard of it was Diego Sanchez when he was just off the
ultimate fighter.
He goes,
and it's one of those vibrating.
I get one of those and he's fucking,
he swears by it.
He's got one that he's making that he's making available,
like I dunno,
1500 bucks,
something that's doable for the public and because they were like 12 grand or
so,
they're expensive.
But if it's a turbo sonic does,
he's all into all credible of that.
I know like high end actors that use them for like,
but they do mobilization with them.
That's not the same machine.
A shaky machine.
This is actually sound.
It's actually sound that goes through your body.
Yeah.
It's a very interesting thing.
The Russian cosmonauts using it or not?
It's a shaky thing.
Yeah.
But it's,
it's actually sound.
It doesn't make any noise,
but it's,
it's a speaker underneath the base of it.
The base of it is essentially like a gigantic speaker.
I just used my head tachy
it's,
I don't think we to say,
um,
it's a really fascinating thing.
It was a,
the Russian cosmonauts use it to stay in space much longer than anybody else was
able to.
Crazy without muscle atrophy and all that.
Yeah.
Well that was the big thing.
That's the big issue.
That's how Brian does it too.
It's how he keeps that physique that's right.
To Hitachi.
So the thing,
so it's a high,
like I drink it,
look at the fast,
and he talks about intermittent fasting on there too.
And uh,
like I haven't eaten today.
I did a fucking 40 minute workout earlier.
I've been up since six.
I've fucking like,
and I'm not hungry.
I don't get hypoglycemic and all that shit.
But it's not that I've been calorically deficient.
It's that I've fucked,
I don't know how many calories are in my coffee,
but a ton.
I'm drinking a bunch of fat through my coffee.
But Mark Sisson,
the primal blueprint guy,
he talks a lot about it.
And the reason I switched over like that was because he talks about sugar
burners and fat burners,
and he's like,
if you're getting in preponderance of your calories from carbohydrates,
your body,
the mechanism never switches from burning sugars to burning fat.
So it's only burning the glucose in your blood,
which is why you need to eat every couple hours or else he gets sluggish and all
that kind of shit.
Right?
And,
uh,
and he says,
you know,
insulin is a storage hormone.
So every carbohydrate that comes in insulin shuttles it to store as fat for when
we don't have food.
But that never fucking happens because we're never in four or five days
stretches of starvation in America.
And so we just stay fat that way.
And we get hyperinsulinemic and we have diabetes later in life and whatever,
or,
or you just keep adipose tissue where you don't want it.
So the thing he started saying,
he says,
you know,
maybe what you want to do is start eating less than a hundred grams a day.
Going into a state of ketosis kind of the way Atkins was talking about,
but even a lot of fibers,
vegetables and,
and you know,
you can eat a fucking bowl of steamed broccoli and not reach a hundred grams of
carbs and a eat a high fat diet.
Like you get hungry,
you want something to eat coconut butter.
Like I put coconut butter in my coffee a lot too.
Or MCT oil,
like,
um,
what does MCT,
medium chain triglycerides.
It's another thing that,
uh,
talks about fat conversion into energy.
And so like with this,
like there's a lot of different mechanisms that are going on that are making me
stay energetic all throughout the day.
And also if I don't have calories in my body,
my body's mechanisms already turned in and attuned to eating the fat out of my
body for energy as opposed to getting hypoglycemic and falling out and needing
to eat some sugar right now in order to keep going.
Yeah,
we had rich roll on the podcast who's a Vegan,
uh,
ultra endurance athlete.
Poor Guy,
nice guy.
So the Vegan aspect of it,
but he was explaining the whole thing about burning fat,
getting your body to burn fat.
Huge.
You have to,
I mean,
if you want to be healthy,
if you like,
and it's just a little bit of discipline.
It's not like I'm ever feeling like I'm lacking something or something like
that.
It's like you're,
you're saying it all day long.
Yeah.
That's a weird thing about a us with our diets,
man.
It's like if you look at the average person and go to Disney land or something
like that right there,
look at the average person when you see them anywhere,
you are around a giant mass of people.
So many people are so unhealed.
You know,
you got to go to go to the fucking crossfit games.
So I was at beach,
holy
fuck.
I was at the beach and the beach was,
was brutal the other day and I was watching these kids,
uh,
eating chips with their fat family.
Everybody's fat.
Their parents are crap.
California where there's a higher level of like people aren't generally let way
higher level of cocaine.
I don't know.
Is that the cocaine?
No,
there's not that many people in coke.
Dude.
Have you ever done any of this stuff that makes the dude's eat their faces?
Brian Batsauce.
Yeah.
Nah,
it only makes one retard eda face.
I have a feeling that is it good?
Other than that you get to talk to him and to doing that.
Anyway,
that goes pick.
I was down to eat someone's face.
I have a feeling that I've been waiting fucking,
I'm waiting to blame it on basketball.
We all know one asshole.
You know there's like that one motherfucker that's just can't ruin bath salts
for everybody.
Yeah,
he ruined the whole gig.
It was weird.
He just had the mind cheese mad.
We're just talking about that crash,
that turbo sonic site.
It's crazy.
Just us talking about it.
That side is rack this crack him sites.
Let's talk about [inaudible].
You can't do that,
Brian.
You can't even say.
You can't say that you can't,
but I'm just informing
while we're working together.
You cannot put us in danger like that.
Yeah.
That's actually a threat.
If you talk about let's go crash a website,
you're threatening to you to conspire to remove someone's product from business
and the way it's defined in like the Patriot Act,
I'm pretty sure that cyber terrorism now you gotta be real careful about shit
like that.
I'm not bullshitting you got to read,
be really careful what happened with the sonic boom site that your turbo sonic
is that did the device that I talked about that shake?
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
And um,
when we,
uh,
when you mentioned it enough,
people want there that it crashed it out.
Yeah.
Holy Fuck.
You're powerful Joe Rogan turbo.
It's not even that site.
It's actually to me is like watching this for the last few years and we haven't
been around each other a whole lot,
but watching the explosion of a podcast,
like the,
like the way technology moves and like podcasts just happened and how powerful
they are and then the,
the reaching that it does into the world.
It's crazy.
Yeah.
It's not like anything that's ever happened to me before.
There's a big difference between doing shows now,
post podcasts and Pre podcasts like pee,
you know,
I always had fans,
those people that want to come see me,
but it's just a totally different arena.
That's what Ari was talking about.
I'd asked him,
I was like,
how does this make it different for you?
And he's like,
dude,
it's fucking retarded.
It's,
it makes all the difference.
Yeah.
It's,
it's weird.
This is,
this is a,
this is Toronto.
This is me just going on stage in Toronto.
It doesn't even make sense when I hear this.
It seems like a lie.
It sounds like the super bowl.
It was
crazy dude.
For Real.
It's like one of the weirder moments of my life really.
Cause yeah,
cause it doesn't seem real.
Was that like a on the show?
Like a one of the biggest ones?
It was a pretty big,
I've sold out Massey Hall before though.
I sold it out last time.
I was there to Toronto.
Just amazing man.
It's just a great town.
They have a big comedy can be there too.
So we did a,
a show on the night before this.
Uh,
not to be named site where they a have a we'd show and a,
it's super secret.
Only people within the community allowed,
I tweet nothing about it cause I don't know what the laws are.
Lastly,
I want to do is get arrested the night before the weigh ins.
Right.
Not,
not a good career move.
So uh,
we literally landed at nine 30 I called the dude up who runs a show and we were
over that.
We dropped the shit off the hotel and we were gone to me and Tripoli show up at
this place.
You,
we walk in,
we go into the back door and it's just like this party's as people drink and
smoke filled room and the iron sheik is on stage.
Oh yes.
So we here at mother fuck Joe Brolly hadn't motherfuck number one,
Greco Roman number one freestyle wrestling.
You hear him on stage,
like going through his shit.
Wow.
And it's just,
there's so much smoke in the room.
Like it looked,
it's like the room is on fire burn.
Oh yeah.
Well I don't want to say so I did too late.
Did that cyber terrorism that they had,
did they have some good cyber terrorism?
Did they have some good weed?
Goddamn.
Did they have good weed in Toronto?
It's a just as good as California weed.
I think it's universal now.
I don't think,
I think what happened was when the medical movement came along,
the California,
botanists got on it because they could be out in the open about it and they
started to putting out the names of the strains and you know,
and telling you this is 70% sativa,
30% indigo and put all the different hybrids out and then everybody else just
ran with it.
So now I think when you get good weed,
you're getting,
it was,
it's good California weed or it's good.
Colorado,
Colorado is right there with California,
but it looks like Toronto's right there too.
Like they know what the fuck they're doing.
And then Vancouver has like a medical program.
They have like something similar that's like where everything came from the
base.
Yeah.
But half the union was a documentary that I was in a few years back,
uh,
that they've actually shown that the Canadian parliament,
they a,
they actually are using it to educate different Canadian politicians because
most people don't even know the history of why it's illegal or what a big part
it plays in the economy of British Columbia.
Like they don't even know.
But it's,
it's like an,
it's a web holding the economy together.
It's a big part of the industry.
It's one of the reasons why Vancouver is such a wealthy place and people don't
want to accept that,
but it's a fact.
It is a commodity.
It's just as much of a commodity is living in an oil town.
It's just as much of a comma.
It mean that money gets distributed back into the community and there's a
massive amount of evidence and it's tolerated in the weirdest way possible where
it is and it isn't.
At the same time,
it's legal and the illegal,
it's the,
it's like they let it go be criminalized.
Does that either,
I don't even know how they say it,
but you can't sell it.
It's like they bus people,
they find the,
the one of the things in the union,
they found these undercover ones or underground like places where they were
growing it with,
they had electricity running underground.
Like they found those before in America too.
And they also had trains where they had like train cars and the train cars were
all filled with grow house.
They're all grow houses and they just like,
you know,
hundreds of yards of trains filled with weed.
Yeah.
I mean the,
the,
the demand is insane.
The,
and there's money coming in and it's not totally legal.
It's,
but it's a massive part of the economy and the union,
if you haven't seen it.
My friend Adam Score,
he did the documentary and I'm in it too.
It's,
I go crazy talking about weed laws,
but it's a,
it's one of the best documentaries as far as like explaining how ridiculous it
is.
But in Canada they watched this,
they're showing these to politicians.
These fucking monkeys we have in office are not going to sit down and be
educated by something that actually makes sense.
No,
these ridiculous fucking pee.
But we have running this country.
They said that the lobbyists now that that even like companies like the
pharmaceutical companies are big electrical wherever,
that they're,
that they're pushing lobbyists away there.
The the hundred senators that are bought by everybody,
they're like,
we can't,
we've already,
we're already invested.
Sorry.
Like the bribes aren't even counted anymore cause they're already,
they're already the sides already Cozen.
It's the idea that you can just bribe someone to give it another name,
call it lobbyists.
The idea that you can be in fucking office that like that's what you're groomed
for.
Like you ask a 12 year old,
do you want to be a politician?
Kill that kid.
What the fuck?
Weird kid.
Love that George Washington Shit.
Like,
fuck no,
I don't want that.
They're like,
we want to make you king.
He was like,
are you,
what will,
we were just doing it.
You'd ask not paying attention.
We got us got away from that.
You're stupid man.
Yeah.
George Washington is the leader who hasn't wanted to be a leader,
you know?
Yeah.
That's what George Washington probably had to do it because if he didn't do it,
some other client would do it and ruin the whole fucking project.
Clean.
Yeah,
but that was like unpaid.
You're not like the whole thing is like,
it's taking you away from being a businessman,
like a plantation slave owner that he was,
you know,
it's like,
listen,
I got slaves to fuck.
I really don't have enough time.
Exactly.
When this country,
I wouldn't teeth and I own a bunch of people.
What do you think about that?
Did you ever see the,
the uh,
that Obama wasn't the first black president and all the other seven or eight
black press?
I've only seen that from the black Muslims.
They do.
There's a website there is dedicated to it,
but I'm like Calvin Coolidge is how come I never thought of that before.
Cool.
Like my man,
I should've known that.
Yeah.
When was the last time?
I do knew Calvin was a white guy.
Coolidge.
Calvin Coolidge is black as fuck.
Right.
Used to be the article but it on my website who way,
way,
way back.
It was just like way before fear factor.
I was in New York doing a club and I was walking down the street and these black
Muslims,
the black Israelites,
excuse me,
not Muslims,
the black Israelites have a,
they were crazy
outfits like superheroes.
Really?
Oh my God,
you've never seen it.
it's amazing.
It's one of the weirdest religions ever.
They um,
they,
they make fun of regular Jews.
These so called Jews with curly hair and de de de stupid clothes.
This guy was saying that's why he's dressed up like a superhero.
Like I'm,
I'm not,
I'm not joking.
I mean they look like a guy who's in like a move like Charlton Heston movie
about like people who lived in the Roman times and like that's how they're
dressed.
The dress.
Like they dress these crazy outfits and then Marriott and they like,
they will read the Bible,
you know,
say us onto he what you,
and then they would say what he means by that and then come up with some crazy
exiting to keep the mud races and the white man and the like all the different
non African races like whoa.
How'd you get that out?
That sentence?
Awesome.
And you have to see some of the videos of these guys.
Could you would swear it was a,
it's a giant troll.
See if he can pull some up Brian,
because a lot of people are not aware of them.
What do they call it again?
A black Israel lights.
Crazy Black Israelites.
They all hate white people.
The white devil.
And they'll do all this.
And I sat there and watch these guys go off about white people.
He let me sit her out cause yeah,
he goes,
you're not Jewish,
are you?
And I said,
no,
I'm Italian.
Oh,
say some shit.
I've said I'm Italian and go.
Okay,
you ain't even white.
Yeah,
a white.
I'm okay.
Okay.
I'm just,
I just don't want to hear your,
your rap right now,
but a dude asked to take a picture with me.
I wished,
I wonder if the picture's still up on my website,
but the picture was me standing there with the,
it's fucking guy.
The guys.
Where are they?
Oh,
this guy's got an actual Bible open down.
Let me ask you this man.
This man don't as a parent you are racist when you were,
this was
the battle between crazy people.
This is no good.
Well,
I try to try to find one where it's just the other crazy people love just them
guy.
In fact,
guys like saying there's twisting up to scripture.
He's like,
you,
you are doing the wrong crazy shit.
Oh my.
Yeah.
Look at the outfits.
Nicole's in America.
I say sue to do's.
A one shot.
I said that's where you get them.
You get the word tribal?
Yeah.
Who am I?
What's your nationality?
I,
I'm just,
I'm just a person.
No.
What are you calling on?
You quote on the Caucasian?
Yes.
Okay.
When you are getting beat up by telling you that.
What does the Bible tell you that until you genesis chapter,
you guys against the war.
Do you want,
if you want us to know where we were supporting total,
right,
so awesome outfit.
All 12 tribes of Israel are stuck in the I not to say that.
Okay.
I mustn't it.
12 tribes,
negroes and deeds hastens
Panama,
Puerto Ricans,
Cubans,
North American Indians,
the Seminole Indians,
Argentina,
Chile,
Colombia,
Uruguay in the so called Mexicans
again squares.
When Jesus a Jew,
yes,
he wants to do it.
Okay,
so why do you have Jesus painted like,
Oh boy,
oh boy.
That is the family that it's a shock coming out in April and they're going to
give you the whole truth.
This guy's not a good representation of it.
Temptations.
They read up,
they read as a Bible and then they twist it up,
but it's all basically the same thing.
This guy wasn't spewed enough hate.
They all yell.
He was barely doing hate.
He was just doing silly.
He was going silly with it.
He had like a cardboard,
like a,
like a outfit.
Looks like a fucking paper bags from Vons.
John's not gone take a shit on.
Yeah,
it looked like he'd tape tape the trim.
I don't know why.
You have to have a certain outfit in order to read the word.
I've always thought that was really interesting where people dress up and I
don't trust you when you're dressing up special.
I really don't because that's not you.
You know you,
you should be able to go and do a mass in front of everybody dressed the same
way you would dress if you went to dinner somewhere.
Right?
You should just dress.
He should,
he shouldn't wear like crazy outfits or eat different.
If you want to wear a dress,
if that's your shit,
a velvet dress and a big hat.
If you're that kind of Gal and that's what you want to wear,
I think you should be aware or whatever the fuck you want,
but what I don't think you should do is dress like you're from another time
period and I give you extra spec.
It it all the people down in the neighborhood.
I used to live like all the dudes in the black wool suits and all that.
Oh yeah.
And the funny hats.
Some are fuzzy,
a cowboy hat.
Some of like a Christmas was always fucking cracks me up to see those guys
walking and then you'll see a dude with a Bluetooth.
It's like you're in the 1840s but your Bluetooth like that's okay though.
You got to wear this uncomfortable shit all day long.
They only wear that one outfit.
They only,
that's the only kind of clothes they wear.
And I think those poor kids,
you see these young kids and you're like,
fuck yeah,
they're,
they're stuck.
They're stuck in a cult.
But hopefully they can.
And Yahoo,
they're way out of there,
I guess.
A bad motherfucker.
And he was stuck in there.
I feel like you just got to pick your cult.
Yeah,
well maybe,
but that's not the one.
No,
this is too restrictive.
The ones that are too restrictive,
it's to like,
people got out of control and they had a Jujitsu.
That's a call that is for sure.
No Paleo brother.
All the crossfit and that Shit's all cults.
But it's all good.
How do you want to call it?
Radio show that may,
yeah,
exactly.
Culture.
It's got to pick your goal.
Don't get full dumbed down.
Yeah.
Well it's also,
what we were talking about before is this,
people would naturally gravitate towards groups,
groups of likeminded people because w this not everybody's fucking different.
This world,
man.
There's too many different variables that could affect people.
So many variables.
That's why the idea of of a country is,
you know,
it's kind of a,
it's almost like we're,
until we have evolved to next level of consciousness,
we're going to keep having countries.
It's pretty historic.
It's good.
It's gonna be real hard for us to evolve past the point of needing a team pass
the point of needing a tribe,
it's going to be real hard because some other cuts going to come along and you
kind of tried to Jack all the resources,
control the area.
You know some,
it's true.
It's if you look at like what's going on in the Middle East,
like how does this not blow up eventually?
How does this not over boil?
You look at that shit.
That's going on,
whatever.
At least they have real food.
You look at what's going on with Gmos and with Monsanto and fucking the head of
Monsanto gets appointed as the head of the FDA by Obama.
It's like,
I want it to be on your side,
homeboy,
but holy fuck.
You know what I mean?
It's like,
we're like,
we're just controlled.
I mean,
controlling our food,
poisoning our food.
Monsanto made Agent Orange.
Yeah.
There.
Oh,
fucking weed fertilizer company for Fuck Sake.
Yeah.
That makes our food that owns,
if you eat any corn at all,
it's Monsanto corn.
It's all GMO.
It's all mutated.
The wind,
the way they shut down fucking farms,
they'd put a farm next to it and then they'd fucking sue them.
They'd say,
you're growing our shit.
They're like,
the wind blew and fucking your shit is here.
Right?
Say we patented that.
Yeah,
and then they send a farmer's bankrupt.
Bankrupt them.
Yeah.
That's common practice in now.
It's a done deal.
Every 30 seconds,
commit suicide because they're,
they're involved in a Monsanto contract that they can't,
they can't profit from,
and it stinks.
Well,
they're there.
They're Sunni Kenny.
Uh,
they're the only country that's doing a corporation and they're in a lawsuit.
They're in a litigation on though because the egg plant,
they're trying to own the eggplant,
the way they did the,
uh,
the way they did the corn in America and then like enough's enough man.
Brazil one recently in Coriell.
Yeah.
The Brazilian farmers.
They one billions of dollars from,
how's Arizona cow?
Those fucking Brazilians know how to do me.
They fuck.
Yeah,
they do.
Yeah.
And they,
um,
apparently not so good at Jujitsu,
but they got so fucking,
I can cook some shit.
There's some suicides all over the world when it comes to the Monsanto.
It's really scary,
right?
Monsanto's connected to 200,000 suicides in India,
200,000.
In the past 10 years.
The past 10 years in 10 years,
man,
I had no idea.
That's insane.
365 days a year times crazy.
That suicide where organisms are dying to recreate themselves.
Like humans,
like everything.
Like,
we're like,
like biology wants it more biology and like,
and you've got to,
you've got a,
uh,
you've got self preservation as a gene in you and where people are dying like
that.
Like fucking what you're talking about suicides there.
Are you talking about the American soldier coming back?
Like it's fucking epidemic,
dude.
It talks about a do today kills himself.
That was in the army.
That's crazy.
And it seems like something we should address in there.
I mean,
you think about that 365 days a year,
10 years.
That's 3,650 years right through or 3,650 days.
3,650 days.
200,000 people commit suicide.
That's amazing.
That's huge.
I mean that's almost,
that's a lot.
That's insane.
And that's just given hopelessness.
How much hopelessness can I give to a guy?
Kills himself.
Is that like 50 a day?
70 a day or something like that.
And I mean it's crazy.
It's going the wrong guy.
Yeah,
I'm the,
I'm the wrong guy.
Questioning.
I think it's been broken down though.
It's someone's broken down.
Like how,
how many minute every three minutes or something.
An Indian commit suicide because in Monsanto,
well India is massive.
First of all,
there's a billion people,
but to extra folks there and Monsanto,
Monsanto's like,
fuck them.
We're going to need to fucking thin to herd some way it was the week pitches to
kill themselves.
So we're just going to jack them.
I don't know what the deal they have over there is,
but I know that there's certain places in this country where these,
uh,
these,
they,
they make deals with people where you have to buy their shit and once you buy
their shit,
like it only works for a year.
They have like suicide seeds that don't work and then you've got to buy it from,
you're strung out on him.
Yeah,
you're strung out.
You can't like the old days a farmer,
he used to take his tomatoes and then take some seeds from those tomatoes and
plant those seeds and make more tomatoes.
That shit ain't happening anymore.
They've engineered that out of the equation up,
which is really nuts.
Right.
But they've twisted mun twisted it around.
They've twisted life around just so they can maximize the amount of money.
It's not like you couldn't make money just selling.
See,
just read them on side.
One of the,
the Monsanto headquarters,
they all vote on what their cafeterias.
They voted no GMO foods in our cafeteria.
Is that awesome?
They're like,
we're not even that shit.
That's hilarious.
So then what is that shit?
Those are the people that know the most about that food.
So what the fuck is that?
Well,
it gives tumors to rats.
Like they,
they're just a released in studies now that show that a kiss fucking rat's brain
tumors.
It just shows you gotta be more proactive,
know more about your life.
You believe the government,
you deserve to die.
You like,
it's a,
it's like if you take Fletcher law,
if you're looking at,
if you're looking for somebody else to be relying on so you can get your health
and you're like,
that's fucking,
that's one way of looking at it.
I think the way I look at it than I would choose is that there's,
there's gotta be a way that these people can profit,
that everybody can make a living and do very well by selling a legitimate
product that doesn't fuck people over.
We just got to figure out a way,
what is that evil?
We've got to figure out a way to stop people from putting money over humanity
and that's what they,
that's the firm like that documentary.
The corporation.
Do you ever watch that with a basically,
well,
yeah,
and that's not,
we don't leave companies.
People vote and they say,
what's going to be better for my taxes?
They don't say,
what's going to be better for the homeless guy down the street?
Well,
fuck the homeless guy.
You know,
that bitch needs to get a job.
What's his problem?
There's a,
there's a lot of stuff that goes on with that.
There's a lot of mental illness.
I mean,
I'm just saying that's how people look at it.
You'll receive this document I'm not inclined to do anyway.
I am once,
yes,
I have.
I think once you get to be like a dude and you're pissing yourself and you're on
the street,
like the bring you back to baseline and build you up again.
God Damn,
that's an effort.
You know?
I'm not saying we may be doing it,
we're going to do that.
I'm not saying we shouldn't do it,
but I don't know what made that guy.
But some something went wrong and created that dude.
We definitely need to patch this fucking thing up one way or another.
And having a company like Monsanto around and helping shit.
Oh,
and then what is that like when you talk about like every book,
every country except for like three countries in the fucking world.
The central bank has a Ross child's bank.
Oh.
Like you think about things like that about like why,
who go Chavez is a outcast and treated like Castro is is because fucking he
said,
I'm not going to sell my natural resources to the World Bank and a swatch.
My debt.
Like when you,
when you look at that and you go,
it's about money and control and you go how much money you can draw.
Like how,
how many more billions do you need?
Like what?
What is that about?
Or,
or like you look at the thing where the word,
they break the oil pipeline and Halliburton comes to the rescue again.
Fuck you.
You know how to clean that up.
Nobody knows how to clean that up,
but you got a contract to clean it up.
It's just more fleecing the taxpayer.
So we're paying for our own imprisonment,
like,
and,
and that's the real rub.
That's the whole game here is how can I keep the American public or all the
public scared so that I can make you pay for your own imprisonment.
How can I,
how can we spin the euro so that the World Bank in fucking in Germany can by
Greece,
it's not just taking corporations were Jack had countries like that's crazy.
It's,
and it's all from,
it's all based on someone's going to try to make money.
Right.
That's the only thing that everything is based on.
It's not even money,
it's Po.
It's like it's sicker than that.
It's like a junkie.
It's like when you tell me as a dope fiend and you go,
if you're absent,
if you have one that's too many and a thousand's never enough.
It's like there's,
it's an insatiable lust for power that they crave that because you've already
got opulence for forever.
So what is it?
It's just like we were talking about with the prison guard experiment.
It's just human nature.
When humans get to a certain point where they have ultimate control over people,
they look at the regular people with disdain.
They separate themselves from everybody else.
They,
it becomes a team of them.
You know,
these,
these blueblood Weirdos who were fucking eyes wide shut masks and,
and go around fucking each other in the ass on videotape so that they have
something on each other or whatever the fuck they do.
Those,
uh,
it's,
it's just like anything else,
man.
They just have too much power.
It's too,
they manipulated the system.
There's a rig system and they're,
they pass money down from generation to generation and there was an enlightened
person teaches unenlightened children.
They remain that way and it goes on and on and on and it doesn't match up to the
model of information that's out there now.
It's not at this,
it's not like we're living in the 15 hundreds where it's really tough to get
worried out.
No one really knows how the fuck anything really works because the whole,
the whole country's in the dark.
You've got to go to the library and books.
You can't,
you know there's no cars.
It's like that era too,
to get something by.
In that era it was almost like balanced.
It was normal,
but now it's imbalanced because everybody knows it's a hustle.
It's not like it's,
there's no confusion anymore.
Anybody can go online and Google the stories about Monsanto.
Anybody can go online and Google lobbyists and find out how that whole thing
works.
Anybody can go online and read what people are saying that I've actually read
the Nda and what a fucking crazy thing is that Obama passed this.
Anybody can do that now.
And this wasn't the case when this sort of style of government was was born.
It's just evolved to a point where it's gotten too big.
What's so funny though,
too about people,
because nobody cares.
It's like after the Bush administration,
the,
the robbery was obscene and blatant and nobody cared.
Nobody cared that he didn't really have a grasp on the English.
No,
but nobody cared.
Nobody cares about Mitt Romney.
How crazy he sounds.
He's like,
you can't roll down the window and an airplane.
And so you can't get fresh air in the plane.
Somebody's got to fix that.
Like,
what is that like?
That's insane.
You're an insane fucking person.
You're nearly retarded and you're vying for one of the highest offices.
But that's not the crazy part.
The crazy part is there's grips of people that are on your side because he's
white.
It's so,
he's a businessman.
He's white in the fact that he's a businessman.
The fact that he's been rating companies and fucking humble jobs away,
the video tape of him recently where he's going,
yeah.
Um,
the 46% of Americans that are just taking from the country,
they're just scabs on the country and we've got to stop that.
Oh,
these are people that we're paying into,
into all these social programs.
That's who he's talking about is retire reason shit.
And it's all he's talking about.
He said,
what are you saying?
That 47%,
apparently I didn't know this,
but 47% of the people in this country don't pay income taxes.
They don't make enough money to pick up in crisis.
And it was like those people,
I don't worry about those.
And they still pay taxes because they pell up pay property taxes,
they pay
taxes,
everything.
But he was trying to say that they don't contribute to,
they'll never,
they'll never vote for him.
And everybody was like,
what did you say?
Crazy so crazy.
Like you can't concentrate on them.
It's like,
well,
you can't concentrate on half the public on people.
Yeah.
And a half the people,
you can't try to talk to them and explain to them that you can help them.
Whoa.
Like he's an elitist.
He's as clear and elitist as it can be and I'm not into,
but Obama's done.
I don't like it.
I guess it makes,
it makes me sad.
That's a bummer that really had the first black guy that's president who's a a
liberal who's a brilliant guy,
who's Harvard educated and this is the result,
the National Defense Authorization Act,
all the,
the,
the ridiculousness that's gone on with wikileaks.
Make anybody a terrorist.
You got zero rights in court.
We can hold you in.
Definitely all of that shit dude.
And like,
and for him,
what I was hoping for,
I'm hoping the second term it is,
he just played ball the first.
That's my,
that's my fantasy.
Which I know isn't true.
Chris Rock's been saying that like,
you know the second terms and you do some gangster shit.
I'm like,
come on.
We'll see.
That's her date yet,
if that's really the case,
first of all,
you can't freedoms,
freedoms taken away or never returned once you'd give away some freedom.
It doesn't ever,
never in the history of the world hasn't gone back.
And I'm sorry,
retards.
It's not World War II.
Freedom where your great granddaddy and World War One or something you fucking
asshole.
It's people that came and carved a fucking country out from England.
That's the freedom that was fucking bought from with a wholesale clean slate
place like that.
We don't get that shit back.
And ever since then it's slowly sliding away.
And those guys that built it back then,
they knew,
they knew that this could fucking fall apart.
So they put a bunch of safeguards in place and essentially lately the
politicians had been cutting those up and selling those down the river and all
without the support of the American people.
We haven't told nobody was even in this war that no one,
no one's for it.
Not only he's known for it,
most people don't even know what's happened.
I mean,
I've talked to friends that are like really politically active supposedly,
and you bring up the national defense authorization act and because it's done on
CNN,
right?
They uh,
they think like,
well,
what the fuck?
You know what?
They get to keep it off CNN,
keep it up.
You've got to listen to Jamie Kilstein or you've got to listen to fucking,
you got to go to other places for that.
You know,
even BBC,
if you go go online,
you could find information about that.
But BBC,
Al Jazeera,
all that Shit,
you know,
that's,
um,
terrorist.
Yeah,
it's motherfuckers,
it's weird,
man.
We got a weird world we live in.
Dude.
It's very weird.
Strange.
We've got this woman coming on next week,
Amber Lyon,
she's from CNN.
She seems interesting.
Yeah,
very interesting.
She's going to,
she's going to break open some massive,
she's gonna.
Well,
she exposed massive,
uh,
censorship at CNN.
She kind of told what it's like over there and,
uh,
we're gonna sit down with her next week and they'll treat her like wikileaks.
Well,
it goes to that thing about with the family on the train tracks,
it's too obvious at this point.
It's too obvious.
It's too,
it's too obvious that they're censorship when there's issues,
especially like the National Defense Authorization Act,
which is really an unconstitutional act.
It's,
it's horrifying when you read what they can do.
A indefinite detention of American civilians who uh,
essentially have no recourse,
no right to trial.
They can just detain you.
You don't have rights anymore.
It's like the whole idea of this country is innocent until proven guilty.
And the reason that is the case is because there's a lot of people that got
accused something that weren't guilty.
It's that simple.
Think about trusting the TSA,
the guys at Tsa that you walk up on cause that,
that that's who is going to enforce this stuff.
Are People like that then a detention under those rules.
Drooling.
They can't control what they eat,
they can't control anything.
Their flatulence is,
is,
is more widespread than mine.
And their idea behind this is that what they're doing is preparing for a fucking
Arab spring tide.
Right?
And we're going to,
we're going to be able to have these things so we can legally do the things that
are horrible and immoral.
But with,
since we wrote them down on paper,
we can do it now.
So we're going to do,
right.
So we're just going to set it up nice and slow.
Well,
we changed the country and literally turn everything into a police state.
Oh,
and by the way,
we're going to have drones.
Do you mind if we have drones?
We're,
we're just thinking of Pat labs.
Pass it.
We know what we're doing.
Don't,
don't worry.
We're going to have 30,000 of them floating in the sky in the next 10 years
talking to people last week about this and there.
And the thing is,
is like with the people that did vote for whoever,
whoever your candidate is,
whatever.
But the people that are so easily fleeced in the country,
the you go,
um,
if,
if it's,
you know,
we pass a law,
it's a,
it's okay to fuck your kids now.
It's totally okay.
You can have intersects intercourse with a child.
Then they go,
well,
it's legal.
At least it's not illegal.
It's like,
it's such a fucking battle cry for numbskulls.
Yeah.
Well the passed a law in New York City recently saying that rabbis have to get
consent from the parents before the Moyle sucks on the kid's Dick after
circumcision.
Because a couple kids have died over the past few years because of herpes.
So these asshole rabbis and kill you.
Yes.
When you're a baby,
yes,
herpes can kill you.
So these rabbi assholes with cold sores are sucking off baby Dick's and giving
them,
this is not,
I'm not making any of this as part of the thing.
So they pass a law.
So now there's a law that says we have to just get the parents' consent and you
can still do it.
You can still suck a baby's deck because it's a religious practice because it's
a religious act and they do it because it says that in the Torah that you know
he's supposed to do it with your mouth because it's the closest thing to it.
And because saliva has antiseptic properties,
because this is how people lived thousands of years ago.
So when they perform the circumstances and the traditional method,
the island,
yeah,
it was plenty of antiseptics.
Although put in pure on a baby's Dick after he cut it seems rather cruel body.
There's going to be fine.
Toughen them up.
Toughen up that boy,
he's scared of pure oil on the deck.
I don't know all that shit that's out there.
Then what do you do with it?
What's the recourse when you've got like there's nothing you can do to make that
illegal first of all,
but you can't,
you can't fight maybe sticks.
You can't,
you can't fight that.
Well,
I just,
it's so disappointing that a guy like Obama was the one who came up with this.
So then what's the recourse or not just came up with this rather,
but approve this in in office.
He had a stand.
He had to do a JFK there.
He had a stand up for that.
If you're going to be a real president,
you have to stand up for that and you have to expose it to the public and say,
look,
this is an issue that I can sign and this is why.
And make a stand and say,
listen,
you guys can make a lot of money,
but you can't do this.
You can make plenty of money still.
You'll have plenty of control.
Why aren't you talking about that at a state of the Union address?
You know what I mean?
It's like why isn't it?
Why?
Why isn't everybody?
Why isn't it?
Why isn't it a huge issue?
Then the whole,
there's no power.
Yeah,
there is.
He just turned off my power though.
Really?
What went off my laptop.
My laptop is not getting any power.
Oh,
now it does.
So it wasn't working,
dude.
I was getting no power for some reason when I turned it off,
that's the switch is probably
not in the connection,
but I just turned that off and back on and now it works.
I didn't touch it before that and it wasn't on magic.
It's probably that mag shit's going to blow up.
Well,
this is a building that's super crazy old.
This place has been here since like 1961 really?
Yeah.
So the electrical system in Harris really wonky.
Was the,
was the cannabis shop,
was that here before you guys came in after you got no,
they were,
they were here before us.
We've only been,
I started up there,
I did my first show here in 94 but we've only been like hanging out here on a
regular for like what,
two years?
Probably two years doing shows here.
So the,
you know,
this,
the weed store was already here kid,
this whole area.
It's like very weedy.
There's a lot of weed going on in this area.
Yeah,
I think it's real weird.
Like where you can get away with certain things where you can like teach people
how to grow and Shit and they have hydroponic shops and they don't come down on
you.
But this is areas like,
but then you go,
you were in San Diego,
you can't rock that shit in San Diego and,
and Palm Beach.
They just,
they're closing down in Palm Beach.
They're trying to stop.
But then for this stop they put a moratorium on him that you can't open any
more.
There were so many,
it was so crazy.
That was awesome.
In New Mexico,
they opened them up and uh,
they said that they legalized it for Matt,
but there's like 10 prescriptions they gave out.
They will give anybody a card and then there's not really any,
they didn't think it out really.
It doesn't seem like anywhere where they go dispensary's have to meet these
criteria and then,
or any of that kind of stuff.
And so they're like,
nobody can be a dispensary or maybe anybody can or they're not sure.
I think it's at 13 states now.
I think 13 states out of 50 have some sort of medical marijuana program.
The interesting one was Rhode Island,
we're Rhode Island's said they would use their state police to fight off federal
agents if they came down to close the lowly shit.
Yeah.
Rhode Island saying you're not going to arrest you Rhode Island citizens for
this.
And I was like,
wow.
Rhode Island went gangster with the Fed.
Good.
Because they were coming in and just arresting people for who are not violating
state law,
which is unconstitutional,
which is more shit.
It's a,
there's a reason why it's set up this way.
So for the federal government to come in and say that,
you know,
we're a superseding your state government,
that's,
this is a reason why there's a state in the first place.
It's so the federal government can't do that.
And the only time starve,
the only time it was supposed to be where the federal government has power was
when we were in a state of war.
So we're in a constant state war all the time.
It's just been a constant state of war.
So we always can have the cities like there's real problems and like Sacramento,
uh,
where,
where is it?
Uh,
to macro myth.
The hat right then with the [inaudible] are bankrupt that now their pensions of
all the firefighters there,
all the cops that have retired,
sorry,
we can't fucking pay.
You were bankrupt.
Like who is that fucking accountant?
Like,
like you're just stealing so much that the state is not that the,
that the state can't take care of this city that's bankrupt.
That's a major metropolitan.
Like that's crazy.
There's like three in California right now,
but we're going to go ahead and send federal money after some guys smoking weed.
What was really important is that we police Afghanistan,
we're going to make sure that everything's okay over there.
We went,
they got their training people and then the people were just turned their guns
on the American troops just gunning him down.
Thanks.
So getting freebies.
They get a good to give them a gun and they just gone down American troops.
I mean it's,
it's happening on a regular basis now.
Suicide bombings and all kinds of craziness over there.
Dude,
we had this guy,
Shane Smith from vice vice.com on who told us about interviewing these guys who
had kids strapped with dynamite.
They're talking about how they use kids as devices to to to to detonate bombs
like a vehicle.
Yeah.
It use it as a vehicle for delivering a bomb that's a child.
I mean it's scary shit and we're like,
well we need to be over that.
We need to,
we need to keep that place in line.
Like what,
what,
what kind of a shit job are we doing of keeping that place in line if they've
got children,
suicide bombers on the regular site,
is there anybody that doesn't love their kids?
Like everybody that has kids loves kids unless they're really fucked up.
It's not like you can't sell me on the whole thing.
Afghanis,
they just don't like their kids.
That's the way Afghanis are like,
that's fucking silly.
It's like in North Africa where my friends would go on merchant marine boats and
they'd go,
dude,
there's people just,
they're fucking limbs cut off.
And I thought it was an epidemic,
but they said,
no,
it makes them better beggars like in India and so they'll disfigure main
children because the best place you're going to get in life is as a beggar.
Like that's how some places in the world are.
And so the the the best,
they're so frustrated and so fucked in Afghanistan or if you want to talk about
anywhere in the Middle East where they're like little strap bombs on people and
go,
it's like,
that's not crazy people.
Those are people that are so fucking frustrated with their empty position that
they're either going to kill themselves like the 2000 people that are doing over
Monsanto in India,
or they're going to fucking try to make a statement while they do it.
Yeah,
that's fucking crazy.
Let's look at that shit.
Roll the dice being born there.
Imagine being born in Kabul and what are you going to do for those people?
Yeah.
A couple of guys at the m 16 are going to get take care of that problem.
Really?
Yay.
Seems above their pay grade.
He ain't getting out,
bitch.
You ain't going nowhere,
right?
Where the fuck are you going to go if you're born and like Somalia?
What?
How?
What is the best you can do be a pirate?
You think so?
Yeah.
That's the best shit,
right?
And there's nothing else.
You're going to starve or you're going to be like Tommy Lee at the club.
Like,
I'm going to be a pirate and it's gotta be a way to figure out a way to have an
impact on people to the point where politicians are force to recognize that we
need another sort of a,
another reconsideration of the way we're running things that we need to like,
uh,
like to sit down and like really plan this thing out because the corruption that
we have,
it's not,
it's,
it's not that it's necessary,
it's just,
it's corruption is necessary the way it's run right here.
You got to figure out a way,
if you could figure out a way to get the internet wirelessly and throw it
through the air,
how can we can't figure out a way to navigate humanity,
right?
How can we can't figure out a way to make things fair for cause they,
both of those,
the unfair is what they like.
I know,
but isn't it funny?
There's the just pussies that want,
they,
it's like they want the cheat codes to the video games.
You know what I mean?
They don't want to actually play the games.
Who Runs Shit?
It's amazing.
It really is amazing.
It's mainly looking at like Tesla and you look at what happened with like,
he's like,
I can take electricity from the air and give it to everybody for free.
They're like the fuck you can.
Yeah.
And then all his shit gets destroyed.
Like that's crazy.
Well Tesla apparently was really nuts too though.
Yeah,
they say that he had,
well he had a relationship with a pigeon who was in love with a pigeon.
We can't judge.
I'm not judging,
but I'm just saying I think in order to have the kind of mind that can create so
many things,
I mean Tesla was involved and it wasn't it either.
It was telling me about that though about like when like that he thought that
sex was such a distraction that he had to destroy his sexuality.
Yeah.
That's a guy like a fucking wicked genius.
He thought of the radio like they could do that.
Like that guy.
What?
What does destroying his sexuality mean?
Like that's crazy and that that wasn't encumbrance.
Like,
I'm sorry,
I'm thinking about science too much.
To think about my dick ever that's had some sort of little relationship with a
woman that really rectum and it was like really,
he was really twisted and confused by it and it really fucked him up.
So there was a quote that Tesla had destroyed his sexuality.
That was the,
um,
hmm.
That was the quote that he had destroyed his sexuality,
which is really fascinating,
man.
I don't know what that means,
but I guess he made a conscious decision.
He liked to said,
you know what?
This is obviously,
this is a problem.
This thing is fucking my life up.
And he was willing to put his money where his mouth is and,
and,
and stop the ball flow.
I know a scientist,
she was,
uh,
he,
he like made all kinds of shit.
He was on like monster garage that,
that,
uh,
what's his name,
Sean.
And um,
wrote for like scientific American and shit does all kinds of different shit but
thought I'm an I'm an experiment and I want to change myself into a woman and
did it like a homemade,
that would be a fascinating one for your show.
This fucking lady did a homemade sex change and became a woman.
Ooh,
who's like homemade.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Like with,
no I don't think did any hormones or maybe self administered hormones and like
self surgery too crazy.
I don't know if it is a self surgery fully but I ended up getting it.
It doesn't feel the same and it smells different
and they said that a Unix,
there's a study,
a study that just came out,
a study of over 80 unix from the Cho Sun Dynasty,
which ruled in Korea from 1392 to a 1897.
They looked at the world's only record of Unix lives and compared them to
genealogical records of other men of similar social rank and the research cross
check the results with other royal records and what they found was the average
lifespan of a unit and a unit because someone has their Dick and balls cut off
was around 70 years,
14 to 19 years higher than those of a non castrated man of similar social
standing.
So what do you think it is?
They were just like in less danger.
Less stress is probably just dealing with women.
Probably just dealing with the stress of chasing pussy.
It's like really bad in your heart.
These crazy fuck
well how many people would even get out of bed really if it wasn't for some
pussy at the mother to go work out or whether to go make money.
It's like it kind of drives a lot of us guys to get out and do stuff.
Yeah.
Becomes the main motivating factor for a lot of people,
especially early in life.
And then I wonder how like Unix start,
why,
why were they made units to get taken care of?
There was something on servitude.
Right?
And so they're taken care of if they're like on welfare in a way they're,
they're a completely socialists unit so they don't have any stress about money
or about who's going to steal their pigs or any of that shit.
Right,
right.
They're probably,
I mean it said dynasty,
so I'm assuming that's like kings,
right?
Right.
So the,
that's interesting.
Castration,
which removes the source of the male hormones and clean crease increases
lifespan and animals.
Try it guys.
I'll tell you what man,
I had my dog fix when he was five and he,
he changed,
he got real tired all the time.
He got lazy.
He just wanted to lay down.
It was sad.
I was sad to watch and sad.
He was always horny and shit.
So I was like,
ah,
I think I need to get them fixed.
It's just poor guys like using,
you know,
the doctors will tell you,
yeah,
the doctors are telling you it's important.
One point in time.
His,
uh,
his balls were aching.
I thought he was,
I thought there's something wrong with them.
Who's like going down the stairs and he was Yiping.
I was like,
what's the matter buddy?
So I wound up taking him to the vet and the vet,
the vet said there's a dog in heat your neighborhood.
And he was,
his dick and balls were hurting so bad because the dog and heat that he couldn't
walk downstairs.
He would.
Yep.
And I was like,
this poor guy's tortured.
It's not,
you're got steady pussy around them all the time.
The vet,
the don't give him a release date.
I don't think so.
I'll be the bet.
The bet.
Imagine if that's what they do.
Why wouldn't you?
That's a towel.
Yeah.
Well the vet supposed to suck the penis.
Imagine if there was like,
dude,
I had a bully.
Just things for that motherfucker has not came out,
you know,
the knot and the penis,
the dog that connects them to like,
so they ensure and sedation and fucking,
uh,
it came out past the sheath of his skin.
I just,
I looked at that poor fucker and he's just,
hey,
hey.
Not Happy at all.
I'm like,
good luck with it.
You know,
like I just got to wait until the swelling goes down and gets and goes in.
But it's like you could see it almost tearing the skin back to fucking go back
and like,
oh,
you know,
this is a funny thing about animals that,
that crazy desire to breed in bees,
especially in honeybees.
The male honeybee has sex with a female honeybee and his dick explodes.
Okay.
His Dick Lodges inside of her breaks,
off pops his balls literally burst.
His testicles bursts and his penis breaks off inside her and he dies.
He like bleeds out the honeybee.
He's driven to fuck.
Okay,
right.
He fucks and when he fucks,
he dies.
It's amazing,
honey bees get like one shot at fucking the one shot at killing.
They get one shot.
If they sting you,
the,
the Stinger is,
it's,
it rips off that from their abdomen and they die.
They die,
they die,
they die.
When they sting you like it gives me constellation.
Isn't that crazy though?
Widow?
What a shit design man.
What does that,
what do you watch?
Elephant Titus.
[inaudible] this is a sketch.
Remember your testes in you?
What is his from,
from member Johnny dangerously or whatever.
Oh,
that's funny.
That's what it's from.
You are a mad researcher,
sir.
Yeah.
How could you remember that?
Uh,
this was my favorite as a kid.
All right.
Cut it off.
Make sense?
That was a good movie though.
That was back when Michael Keaton was like the man.
What happened to that guy?
You think he just like moved to Malibu and just,
I feel like he got a little throwback from Michael J.
Fox.
I always get those confused and maybe there's a little ill.
Well,
one of them was Batman.
It's hard to remember.
Even Michael Keaton was a good fucking Batman.
It was a good bag,
but I just watched it like four months ago and it totally wasn't,
that goes home or you know,
it was a real,
it doesn't hold up.
But wasn't Jack Nicholson the a,
the job that,
oh,
I watched the one with Denado's.
The Penguin?
Yeah.
Oh and Mike and Michael Keaton was in that one too.
He was the Batman more than once.
Yeah,
twice.
If you've seen the picture of Val Kilmer,
well his head,
the size of a pumpkin and it just says lol.
I used to be Batman.
That fucking poor guy isn't he live in New Mexico to guys.
He's got a ranch out there apparently gets mad at people for going on his ranch
and go fishing on his ranch.
It's like New Mexico is like Hawaii.
Kinda like you can't,
if you're not from there,
like that's one of the questions.
Like if there's beef with somebody or you're on the road,
like there's like,
where are you from?
Like is like,
we're going to fight now.
Right.
You know what I mean?
And,
and uh,
like if you walk around like a Wahoo at night,
like that's,
if you're,
you're going to scrap with somebody.
It's just going to happen.
Um,
in New Mexico is kind of like that and fucking he lives out in this place in
Raton,
whereas like,
I don't like,
you want to,
it's like all families,
old families.
It's the same families that have had different families and they're all kind of,
that's the,
that's the community.
And He,
I guess just pisses those people off,
drives through crazy and the whole or parties
and really it seems like very unwise.
Like that's an indicator of how fucked up he is that he's not even aware of the
danger that he's in.
Yeah.
He's got a,
I think some bad demons.
You know,
he's a movie star,
a big time movie star and he's living amongst like real humble folk folks that
maybe make 12 grand a year.
Yeah.
And he's kind of floating it around.
That's a fascinating and loaded a lot.
Does he have,
does he have like handlers or security?
One of my friends who used to work for them and uh,
it would procure ship for him,
but I don't,
I procure shit for him.
Like I don't know exactly what his life is.
Liking statement cure shift for him.
Yeah.
What happened?
He just decided to like take is a movie star money and just asked,
check out for a few years.
I did a show called a felon.
He was the star,
but he was like absent the whole time.
And then I saw him on some Indian Grammy's type shit and he could barely get
sentences together.
It was like Washington.
It was like watching Bob Dylan performed.
It was just like,
oh,
sad man.
Oh Wow.
But they are talking,
they're intoxicated.
Bob Dylan can't get sentences.
Last time I saw him perform,
it was like a slobbery drunk,
like prob dealing was,
come on.
Really?
Bob Dylan gets hammered.
Oh,
he was at that time.
Where was,
this is on some big award show was like the Emmys or the grammys or something
like that that he was performing.
And I know,
I remember there was a huge black woman that was singing backup that ended up
taking,
taking over kind of force.
It was embarrassingly so,
yeah.
Why have I not heard this?
Bob Dylan drunk.
Dylan sings trunk.
I've never heard this.
I've never heard a bad word about Bob Dylan.
That's one of the weird things.
He's one of those dudes.
It's like,
you know,
yeah,
he had a couple drinks,
you know,
let's give them a break.
Okay.
Brian go to Bob Dylan singing drunk on stage.
On Youtube?
Yeah.
Maybe just old dude.
Old dudes.
Don't tell us.
I could be,
who knows?
Get to a certain level.
You see it?
Okay.
Let's see how drunk he sounds.
Oh,
can you get some volume?
Business seems like a fake video.
Why do you say that?
Because it's all right.
We'll see.
Okay.
What is that Brian?
I'll suss it out.
Do you know how to get noise out of it this time he gets loaded up
and it's got,
what?
What's the tip off that?
It's fake Brian.
Uh,
the,
here it goes.
Oh,
that's just someone being old.
But there was something else.
Well,
if you Google it,
there's apparently a bunch of them.
Bob Dylan drunk.
Another one.
So tell me about your kettle bells.
What about if you want to know?
I want to,
I want to know a,
are they shaping
like mom
can't talk.
Oh,
really?
I can't tell you that man.
You just cause I need to buy kettle bells for the gym.
I gave you some.
Okay.
Yeah,
we'll,
uh,
get you to thumb through on it.
But it's um,
the um,
uh,
the kettle bells that we have are the same ones from Troy.
You know,
those big fat handles.
They're,
they're excellent cause a shit.
What do you still have that?
Um,
Kettlebell,
um,
got across to the Omg to Jim.
Like my Santa Fe 10th planet satellite has got a crossfit gym.
It and Santa Fe.
Are you going to train down here while you're,
while you're in town?
Yeah,
I usually have my down at Scotty's usually.
Cool.
Donna Pico.
Where's he at?
He's like Pico and Doheny.
Okay.
Yeah,
I don't get down there and that plan@westlapolo.com west La Scott Epstein,
many different satellites now.
All how many?
50?
I don't know.
He's got a lot of them.
I want to go see alders too,
dude.
I really want to,
I haven't seen all,
is that a good Moitai Jim too?
Which is a nice little nice.
He's got a lot of fighters there.
Yeah.
I got to find a good Muay Thai gym someplace to do some more time.
I need to mix it up a little bit.
Do you want to spar or what do you want to do is get the guy the whole sheds.
Yeah.
That's good.
I like to do drills to just the,
just the rattling of the dome.
It was not good for you.
Nope.
I know too many dudes who uh,
who are getting a little weird just for foreign.
Don't quit soon enough.
Yeah.
It's a,
it's a tricky thing in it.
I mean,
you retired for folks who don't know,
Tate was on the season to the ultimate fighter three,
three,
three.
Michael Bisping's a year.
You're your best friend.
One take was on that and uh,
you had a couple of fights after that and you're like,
you know,
it's just,
yeah,
it's,
you know,
you just get diminishing returns after a while and you've got to make that
choice I think and go,
what I'm,
what's the payoff here?
And even,
even if you're really getting really big,
big payoffs,
like,
like Kukla del money at that time or something like that,
it's like,
what is the pay off of forever kind of happen.
Like,
like thinking everything clearly.
Cause I haven't been knocked out a couple of times and,
and uh,
and there's times after that where you know that you're not enunciating,
you're not,
or you have to really think,
you have to really put thought into your mechanisms to get the words out
clearly.
And you're like,
but you're thinking it clearly,
but it's just not going to your mouth and you're like,
whoa.
Like when I thought that I'd be like,
Holy Fuck.
And I talked to Jordan about it a lot and he's like,
Yo,
I'm doing crossword puzzles.
I'm like,
me too.
Like every morning we're doing crossword puzzles after sparring,
but it's fucking crazy dude.
But that's what George Foreman said to really?
Yeah.
I don't know that it helped,
um,
not gorge for myself.
You know,
like you,
you wonder,
you wonder what that is and like you,
you would talk,
it always rang in my head,
you know,
that they don't even know till 10 years after the concussion,
what the damages.
And then I start thinking about residual damage.
Like not even knockouts,
but dudes that are just getting jarred.
It's like you'd get in fucking jarred all the time.
And like,
even just wrestlers,
man,
like our football players,
everybody gets it.
It's not just people with head trauma,
uh,
that's directly,
it's like,
it's the vibration in your body and the shaking of the head,
you know?
I mean,
I know stunt men that have it too,
but yeah,
it's,
uh,
it's a real dangerous thing and it's something to really be cognitive about and
to go,
what,
what is enough and where do I go from here and what will the rest of my life
being in?
The big thing I think with fighters especially as like,
here's a bunch of dudes that,
you know,
there's not everybody that's a Kenny Florian or something like that,
that's like a,
and by that I mean like a,
a career in law perhaps,
that he was going to have.
Right.
Wasn't he a law student at one time?
I'm not sure.
But you know,
he's a bunch of highly educated fighters,
you know what I mean?
That,
that are out there.
And now he,
yeah,
he's got a great job as a,
as a,
uh,
analyst and all that.
But
he also has a gym,
you know,
he has his own gym.
I know he still had his brother runs right.
I think he opened up a place in Beverly hills to where he's going to Oh,
right on.
Yeah,
he knows what to do.
I mean,
Kenny Florian is a really smart guy.
There's,
there's that kind of thing and that's only so many guys.
And so then you think,
you know,
all these guys that were working construction or that we're working as bouncers
or whatever,
what,
what am I,
because now I'm a fighter.
It's kind of a herald of thing you get and people are like in the store and they
go,
oh look,
he's a fighter.
And like,
what are you now though?
And that kind of getting to the root of yourself at the end of your career and
going,
who am I without this?
Or,
or if you move to a new place like a new city and you don't have the same job,
you don't have the same friends,
you don't have the same girlfriend,
you're broke.
Like who are you?
Not without any money in your pocket without,
without in any of that.
And really getting to the base of yourself as a human and a,
and it's,
it's a scary question.
I think that that is the reason that guys stay too long in those sports is
because they're like,
well,
fuck,
what would I be without this?
And to me that always seemed like a prison.
Like I never wanted to be in a position where I was going,
oh,
well I'm a slave to this because I don't know what else would be possible.
And I'm like,
I want to live in that infinite possibility that,
that anything's possible.
And let's,
let's go jump off the cliff and see what's down there.
You know,
apparently Bob Dylan was in a motorcycle accident really?
And,
uh,
he was talked into by,
his,
uh,
band and to getting speech therapy because he was in sort of denial about
slurring of the words after the motorcycle accident.
How dare that's apparently the story online for according to some dude on my
message board named Kiam design.
My apologies to Bob Dylan and his family thinking,
Bob.
But I think a good guys that create it probably has some demons probably just
getting lit up every night.
Maybe you just can't,
it's drunk and he's got a head injury.
It's great publicity maybe.
And maybe he was getting hammered and he's like,
I need a good excuse and motorcycle accident,
son.
I'm a victim.
Well,
I remember clearly when a fucking crazy man had that,
uh,
the motorcycle accident where he hit,
um,
the fuck's his name,
the guy who's a,
it's always crazy on those reality shows.
The older guy,
lethal weapon.
Oh,
Gary,
Gary Busey.
Uh,
Gary BC had a legit serious impact with a curb and his fucking head and almost
died and his head change shape.
Like,
if you look at his face,
oh,
curry motorcycle accident post motorcycle accident.
One of his eyes moved up or moved down.
I saw it got fall out of the car today.
Oh,
they're taking it right off of Olympic and uh,
and I saw the door was open on the car and then they go to start taking the
right and the se a hand reach out to grab the door and he bends the corner and
I'm kind of looking back and,
but book dude falls on it.
I was like,
how does that even happen?
It's still way the acids.
In the last week I've seen maybe three or four people fall on the ground.
Like I'm driving and I just see like a woman fall.
I've had three or four times this week.
I've seen it like,
have you noticed any people falling lately?
I guess it's just like a coincidence falling through the chem trails.
I don't know man.
Howard [inaudible] Bravo,
Bravo.
See if there's a,
a fallen conspiracy,
he'll tell you it's orbs,
something in the air chem trails making people fall.
I Dunno.
I mean,
do you think that there's a,
you really think there's a conspiracy that people are falling?
I don't know.
I'm just saying like this week,
I,
for some reason I've seen so many people fall where I'm just like driving by
like,
should I help this person?
Oh,
there's like an ambulance,
right?
Terrible
photo of a person in China today that was run over by a street flattening truck.
They were trying to get protesters out and the guy what stood his ground saver.
Yeah.
They ran over him.
Holos yeah,
it's horrific.
It's like 10 and I'm at square all over it.
Yeah,
it is.
It is.
Yeah.
The,
in China,
they'll still run you over,
man.
You getting,
you know,
they're not quite there yet and though your course did not quite that yet here,
but as long as the government keeps passing shit,
like the NDA that's around,
that's around the corner,
the flattening you with a steam roller and now you can't,
you can't even,
you can't occupy Wall Street,
goddammit.
It's like you can't,
he made that a felony.
Tuh Tuh Tuh uh,
peaceably protest without a permit.
Yeah.
And so now that's a felonious act to go and assemble to protest corporations,
which are fucking government is simply a shadow for anyway.
Yeah.
It's,
it's weird.
Gross.
We,
it's like how much Kenya,
how much can you just enjoy it and just live life and try to,
you know,
to,
to be cool in your own community and be surrounded by Arab you,
you tried to only rock it that way,
but you got to always think that these motherfuckers could come in and fuck up
your shit and think that they're allowed to.
It's like you really aren't that much connected to someone who lives in
Washington DC.
You're just not,
they're too far away.
It's really crazy.
But
someone who's got a boner for you in Washington DC that has power could decide
to use it and find some reason to fuck you over and come after you.
Especially if you're involved in something that they've written down on paper.
It says you're not allowed to,
or even if you're not and you're opposed to that thing publicly,
then you're vilified and another,
you know,
they could do whatever they want to get behind that.
And it makes me think those people just haven't had like some nice steamed
Broccoli and a steak would get yourself a good ribeye medium and go and help
some people will,
it feels fucking better than helping people like go out and help.
Like as far as like,
like Calma,
we can shove people down how we can control people.
How about you help people?
There's an enrichment there and then when everybody does better,
everybody fucking does better.
And it's a fucking universal law.
You Cock sock.
It is.
But the problem is
you're dealing with people that first of all are completely unenlightened and
again,
they're operating.
Did the people that are empowered now besides Obama,
who's essentially a child of the Internet,
I mean he,
he will existed before the Internet,
but he's had massive amounts of access to it since the 1990s when it was around.
So He's,
he's basically grown and maybe not grown up but grown with it.
But the other people that are in,
like,
if you look at it like a Newt Gingrich type character,
I worked Dick Cheney,
those guys are operating on the old way.
They're operating the old way of corruption.
When you can get away with Shit like on Ran Contra,
you could bribe off judges and figure out a way to sneak shit under the door and
change the law.
So it makes what you're doing legal and they,
that is the way they've been rocking it since the beginning of time.
It's going to take the next generation coming up.
It's going to take a hit.
This guy,
David Seaman on the podcast who was a congressional candidate or is it
congressional candidate who's 26 years old and he's a,
you know,
trying to expose all the bullshit that's going on in,
in,
in politics and with the lobbyists and just,
it's,
it's so much for a young guy to take on.
If you really want a career in,
in cleaning up corruption and you want to actually live and not get sniped,
you got to,
you know,
you become a pedophile or whatever else they put on you.
I mean,
they can make him whatever,
you know,
that's the stuff.
Sure.
Yeah.
They can easily go criminal.
We'll give you $5 million.
Like we have that.
That's easy money.
Just get on,
get on,
get on board.
Yeah.
And they can figure out a way to compromise your nice and slow lip,
you know,
nicely and slowly.
They just slow cook.
Didn't they do that with them?
Kennedy,
they brought him down to Cuba and got him some hookers and shit and Marilyn,
Marilyn,
they paid from paid her like,
I think you're making shit up on the dollar.
I see that face.
That's the,
I'm making shit up
that expensive.
What do you think a thousand bucks is worth in the Marilyn Monroe days?
It's probably like,
could you get a car for 1000 bucks?
That six grand really?
Well,
they were talking about what?
It's like a brand new Mustang.
Like when the fastback came out like six [inaudible] five like 3,500 bucks or
something like that.
Ooh,
Mustang 19th pricing.
Let's go with 1963
because I think a fastback,
if you've got a fast back or he could have Maryland for a week,
like that's probably comparable.
Yeah.
I don't know what a fastback or Maryland for a week.
No,
you need a fleshlight in a Mustang.
That's what you need is pretend week you kill yourself.
You'd be like,
I can't believe I've got to have a fucking 1960 you gotta have a stash light.
I could add a VA.
I'm going to have a flashlight party tomorrow.
Oh,
are you really fascinating?
Are you going to are going to talk to girls there?
Bronx.
This Texas is going to be there.
Oh,
the big old booty on her on film.
Proof that we,
that men don't give a fuck about skinny like stick figure type chick,
thick legs and as much.
At least five pounds while we're not having a smile.
Oh yeah.
In what?
She's blowing guys.
She's smiling,
always wanting to meet her.
These are all mustangs for sale.
It doesn't really say what it costs back then.
Oh wait a minute.
If we do like a price circa,
there's a bunch of different sites.
See Martinez?
I don't know who that is.
Who's Missy Martinez?
My new CEO.
You know like you're ahead of the curve kid.
He's got the ones that just moved from Arkansas had been here three weeks.
Kayden Kross you know her?
She's hot.
Yeah,
I've seen her before.
Sam Aaa.
Sam Aaa is the,
he going to be there with the twins.
I hear Bryan County is going to be there.
That seems like a bad idea.
Why is that Brian?
Why is it a bad idea?
Just so many hot chicks.
He's going to go crazy,
man.
He's a handsome guy.
He's going to kill him with his comedy.
Who's better looking than Brock?
Callen really romantic.
And then next in line,
Brian,
I'm still waiting for Brian to take me to olive garden.
Oh,
it can happen.
And what's going to happen when you get that tape?
We're going to have a hell of a sensible meal.
We're going to have butter,
coffee,
and what happens at all?
I've got,
I don't even know what happens behind those doors.
Brian evade at all the garden east soldier with Hick.
A soldier had hiccups.
Okay.
And one soldier was trying to scare this soldier out of his hiccups and the way
he did it was shooting him in the face.
That would work,
I guess to cure the hiccups.
That seems like the worst excuse for shooting your buddy ever.
And he's being charged with manslaughter.
This is just murder.
No,
because he had a stupid excuse.
He pulled out a gun in order to scare him and stop the hiccups and the gun went
off.
It's crazy.
And he blew the guy's brains off.
I feel like if you make that poor decision,
we should put you in prison anyway,
regardless if it's manslaughter or whatever.
When you think about these guys that had been over there and I've seen action,
you know,
if you've,
if you've ever seen some of those soldiers against the Iraq war with a,
uh,
they,
they talk about all the different shit that they're commanding officers told
them to do.
And the first guy who gets a knife kill gets like days off and like you to kill
people with knives.
And um,
do you go from that to like the regular world?
It's true,
yeah.
Thing.
Yeah,
you can't,
it's almost like you have to,
as it were like in,
in black water or that were forced recon marines and Shit.
And it's like that's a,
it's a different thing that they live with.
And the years,
I think like maybe,
maybe never six years or something before,
like my one buddy didn't want to shoot himself in the face like every day
afterwards and you lived through shit like that.
You're,
you're,
you're at a year,
you at a young age and you're asked to do horrific,
unimaginable things for a cause that then it comes to light eventually.
If you're a thinking person all like,
we're not even supposed to do,
like,
this is unjust.
Isn't it amazing how our depictions of,
uh,
like if you look at like theatrical depictions or you know,
a romantic movies about war,
very little of them dealt with the real horrors of war.
Look at our fucking news.
I mean if you go to Spain or something and look at the news,
there's bodies,
there's body parts,
there's,
there's the horror of what death is.
And here in America we don't have any of that stuff we've got,
that's why we have 9% unemployment in Spain has 25% is that why?
That's the reason it's bad.
It keeps people out of work.
I have no idea.
If you want to see violence on TV and reality on TV,
you hate America.
Oh,
we're not ready for that.
that makes sense.
Who do I vote for?
You imagine what it's like for people that have this like,
well,
I've talked to a fucking guy.
I talked to a guy who was at the ice house a couple of weeks ago who came and
told me about,
uh,
he actually joined the army to,
to try to pay for school.
And then a month later,
September 11th happened.
Oh yeah.
So he got shipped off to Iraq and he was telling me about what an insane cluster
fuck it is and then how when he first got there right when he got there.
So I was like,
Yep.
He was like,
well,
you know,
I guess at least we're coming over here getting rid of a dictator,
getting rid of stopping something like September 11th happen again.
And then his commanding officer said,
what the fuck are you talking about?
We're here to get oil.
That's what we're here for.
His commanding officer broke it down for them on the way.
My step mom was like that.
She was like,
well,
we're,
you know,
we're given freedom to those people and this and that.
I'm like,
yeah,
if that were even true.
Tell the mom in Minnesota who just fucking got her boy back in the bag.
Yeah,
about Iraqi Freedom.
Like he doesn't know who gives a fuck.
These are dead people.
Like we're going to push freedom at the end of a gun.
That don't make sense.
The ultimate irony too is cause we,
we got that guy in power,
you know the idea that this dictator,
how did you become a dictator?
You got to dictate it cause he's back like an orange states and then Noriega
says I'm not playing ball.
And they said,
well we're going to kidnap you then a sovereign leader from another country.
We,
we send in special ops and kidnapping.
The only place where they,
they,
they rocket in a healthy way is places like,
like fucking Iceland and shit.
You gotta go,
you gotta go where it's really cold and no one wants to go.
And those people are down for the country.
You would never have.
You don't have fucking food that's bad for you that you know,
you know what I mean?
You can eat shit,
but it's like there's,
there's not,
there's not like a conspiracy to hurt the populous.
It's like the government is for the populace there.
I think it's cause it's small enough.
There's only like 300,000 people in Iceland or something like that.
You could throw bankers in jail,
shit like that.
Yeah.
Well,
I just watched a lawless.
It's fucking,
what does that Rad,
it's a movie about moonshiners and,
and during prohibition,
like Tom Hardy's in it.
Oh yeah.
That's good.
Moving dude is fun,
man.
It's just come out.
Yeah.
I just saw it last night.
I haven't heard shit about that.
You heard anything about that?
It was good.
You're going to like it and fucking and like the way they deal with the law,
they're like a couple sheriffs come through and there you try trying,
you're not trying to,
you're trying to intimidate us and fucking the brass knuckles come out and shit.
And it's like,
it's like,
as long as you're righteous,
everything's cool.
Well,
yeah,
we'll honor that bad.
But if you try to get silly,
you want to extort money from us.
All right.
We're going to talk with a bat.
It's a as how people live back then.
I mean if there was really a time where it was fair,
right,
exactly.
And we look at it,
you know,
it was like good guys and bad guys know it's bad guys in other bad guys.
It's all bad.
It's all bad guys or bad guys and that's,
you know,
we're,
we're the end that where we are as far as humanity has ever gone.
What we are today.
It's September,
what is it,
27th or something and 20 what is it,
25 or six seven or 25th September 25th,
2012 where we are today is the accumulation of error upon error of human error
learning and improving upon that and society moving forward,
technological innovation,
conquering different countries.
We're at the end of that line.
This is like as good as people have ever been ever.
Like right now,
the most capable we've ever best when we think that's the most information
accent about all the sand people.
All those motherfuckers know that people that have turned to sand like the
iPhone.
What about all the other civilizations?
Oh,
the people that go whacked out,
you mean?
Yeah.
I mean they were the most advanced.
They didn't make it.
Um,
yeah.
I wonder,
I wonder if there's been other civilizations.
They keep finding shit
telescope.
You ever listen to that dude?
A black guy used to work for NASA.
Um,
Tyson Degrassi.
Yeah.
Neil Tyson degrasse.
That motherfucker is bad and you get him on the podcast trying to get,
oh,
going back and forth with him.
Oh Dude,
I'll give him a foot massage
oil or dry.
If you wanted oil,
I would do that motion.
You know?
It was nice.
For sure.
Yeah.
I mean,
in my hands are like promised him jerking off of them.
It's like torture.
But I think if there was oily,
advanced societies,
it's very unlikely that they reached this level except for some of the giants
don't constructions.
That's the only thing that makes you like really step back and go,
man,
I'm not sure about that.
Or that it was intercontinental that the same construction existed in different
continents.
That that's crazy.
But he was talking to anyone who's listening,
that dude
the grass or Degrassi.
Yeah,
and he was saying that they have a telescope.
It's like,
I don't know if it's a hundred or a thousand.
What he said times the Hubble telescope was that they could construct,
but it would be $10 billion and that they just wouldn't fund it.
And he said,
to put it in perspective,
what $10 billion was,
is what from 1956 or whenever NASA was created,
what has been in that program since then?
It's been about that.
Or what one month in Afghanistan is,
is $10 billion.
But they won't fucking make this telescope,
which they say they think they could see the origins of fucking time.
That you could look back through space and see the origins,
but we don't want that.
That would upset the apple cart.
Well,
why isn't there an easy good contract to be made in building that thing,
that $10 billion it would cost today?
Wouldn't there be like a company that can profit off of it then you got to get
them on.
He would be fascinating.
Yeah.
Fuck.
That is an amazing thing.
When you really look at that number,
like how much money that is and what it is really.
I mean,
and these guys are talking about,
oh,
the president,
whoever's the Naysayer against whatever president is,
there's trillions of dollars.
That doesn't even mean anything to me.
He might as well say we're headphones in debt like,
okay,
like I don't like cool when,
yeah,
when you get to like be 13 trillion,
it's insurmountable,
right?
I mean is 100,000 ampules in debt like I don't know what any of that shit looks
like.
Okay.
How is it that work again,
the federal reserves,
what is the Federal Reserve?
No,
nobody understands really.
I used to think they understood it until the crash and then I was like,
oh,
you guys don't get it either.
I got a bunch of their fucking a hundred dollar bills.
The old school,
little small head,
they smell or bills,
dude,
they're all in the Louisiana and that.
I'm thinking,
what is all the old ass money that's around here that's just buried and in
mattresses,
like those are mansions fucking everywhere.
At one point in time.
Is it worth anything?
Like when your money goes out of print,
like if you had some civil war era money,
it's not good anymore.
It's gotta be in real good shape if it's good cause I watch pawn wars.
Yeah,
but even then someone has to buy it,
you know what I'm saying?
It's not like you can go in the bank and go,
Hey,
can you give me $1 million?
Right.
This is my million dollars in 1919 no two like they had totally different money
back then.
It's weird.
The gold still has value in that way since it's like,
since it doesn't back in within anymore.
Really?
Yeah.
Right.
What does it mean?
Well,
it's still good for things.
Conducting.
It's a gun.
Aki,
the Ohana knock.
It's good as a conductor,
it's good to,
if you want to have better looking teeth,
he could blink them up.
Do you ever thought of a rock and a gold right here and I was thinking of Dan
Platinum or shot right after the side.
Do you have any dope?
That'd be kind of pirate.
Like people are like,
oh,
your career would be fucked up.
I'm like,
Eh,
like as if looking like Cindy Crawford has ever been my career,
like being more fucked up looking.
Would it be bad?
I look at it,
I got a big old pumpkin head and tattoos everywhere.
Your career.
Isn't that hilarious.
People are so funny about what they think will and won't ruin your career.
Like they got it figured out.
I love that line.
Those that say that tell you how to do it and never did it.
Like there's so many.
It's such an uncharted territory.
The whole thing.
If you want to live a different,
then it's like get up,
go to work,
fucking go,
go back to get married,
go to church.
All that shit take.
You should go super crazy and gets impressed in plants.
My lady that I'm talking about,
she did.
Why would you even say that?
And that doesn't even this,
why would a man want,
cause he's so attracted to me already.
Yeah.
He wants you to be a woman that he wants me to.
He must have had a relationship with Tate.
You would be the woman?
No,
the most of my,
are you kidding me Brian?
We could prove that right now.
I don't know who you think's coming through the door to help you.
Well,
if you want to show off in front of Joe,
oh,
we all know,
we all know where you love lies.
Dog Tait Fletcher Fall,
Tate,
Twitter Tatum,
mess maximus on Twitter and a,
if people are in Santa Fe and they want to go to your gym,
what's The gym?
Undisputed Fitness and find that undisputed fitness.com or crossfit Santa fe.com
and look for Tate and on Friday night to Santa Fe.
Powerful 10 plans.
Did you?
To Santa Fe.
I saw Taten fright night.
It does a good goddamn movie.
That was a good was fun,
Huh?
Fun.
Good vampire movie.
It was like it was a real vampire and not some fucking pussy that can go outside
and sparkle.
I like that it was real dude.
But the big things coming up,
the dude that Arnold Schwarzenegger,
they just started doing a for expendables.
They did the trailer and he's called the last stand and there's a awesome,
there's some awesome shit that I did in there fucking wrecking myself.
But like it's fucking fun dude.
And that's in [inaudible] coming up in January?
No,
no,
they just did the trailer for it during the expendables.
Oh,
what is,
what does that name of that moving the last stand.
Oh yeah,
I heard about that.
Schwartz niggers come back to film.
Is it good?
Is it fun?
Is it was fun to do?
I don't.
Who knows what it looks like after they,
did you hang with him?
Yeah,
he was cool as shit dude.
He was funny as,
I mean he like,
he's got jokes about Maria,
he's like really?
Like he's in the bus,
we're filming the scene and the phone's supposed to ring and it's supposed to be
the terrorist.
Like my boss is supposed to be calling them and,
and they're rolling and I dunno dude,
when like the way I look at it,
like I'm nobody and like when they're like to have a shot fucked up because you
are,
it'd be like mortified,
you know,
he's there.
And their,
their role and they got it going and everything's going good and Dah,
Dah,
Dah.
And the phone rings and he's,
he's like,
hello.
And uh,
he says,
Maria,
I told you to never call me here.
Was like right,
right in front of production on fit.
Like he's,
he's funny man.
He's a funny guy.
He's sensitive tension,
cool,
laid back,
just sets everybody at ease.
He eats in the cafeteria with like,
he's just a fucking cool guy,
man.
Well he's spanking house with me,
housekeepers and maids and shit on the regular.
I heard he was getting back together with the,
that's what I've heard.
I don't know,
but he's super kind,
man.
I don't have a bad thing to say about that dude.
That's an,
he's an interesting cat,
that's for sure.
And all his people were super cool man.
Yeah,
everybody was dope around and we were always definitive sperm.
This constantly something calming all the time.
All the time.
I'm calming,
calming,
calming.
They're either thought about,
I'm like,
what?
What do you call them?
Like Mr Schwartzenegger Arnold,
the governor.
Like cause most people that are in office like they're the governor or the
president forever.
Right.
Then I'm like,
fuck that.
Anybody can be the governor.
Arnold is like,
that's a whole establishment unto itself,
man.
As a boss brand.
Oh,
certainly a brand new.
All right,
well tomorrow we've got Ian Edwards,
Ladies and gentlemen,
very funny comic from New York who's now living here in Los lace.
He will be with us tomorrow and a again this weekend.
I'm with the Duncan Trussell.
Joey Diaz is a no show though.
Some new thing came up that he had to do so he can't make it,
but you can find him mad flavor.
Contact him.
I told Joe Rogan I wasn't doing that fucking Gig this weekend.
A Raleigh North Carolina Friday night where?
At Memorial Hall and Saturday night where at?
In Asheville at the Thomas Wolfe Auditorium and I keep hearing that Asheville is
the shit I heard.
It's so fucking beautiful if you've been up there.
Beautiful.
Supposed to be unbelievable.
It's up in the mountains.
It's supposed to be just gorgeous as shit.
Yeah.
People go there and they go,
I've got to live here.
So we'll see.
We'll see him around my career.
I got a bunch of friends there right now.
They're doing an iron man three out there.
Powerful that I'm wearing right now.
Maybe.
Yeah,
maybe it is.
All right.
Listen,
thanks.
So thanks everybody for tuning in.
Thanks to Tang,
uh,
for being a sponsor of this podcast.
And a,
you can go to rogan.ting.com pick out any one of those delicious super fucking
cool smart phones.
And going through that link will save you 50% or $5.
What is it?
50 bucks.
50 Bucks Bucks.
Say don't listen to me.
50%.
Imagine if that was the deal.
There's that fine other deal.
There's a fun.
So anyway,
go to rogan.ting.com you will get $50 off.
That's exactly what it is.
I shouldn't be allowed to do these freestyle
ting,
uh,
again as no contracts.
All of it exists explained@tim.com,
but it's an excellent service and it goes through sprint.
So go there,
check it out,
use that link and you can cancel anytime.
It's not,
it's not like anything else.
It's,
it's a sweet deal.
Also A,
we're sponsored by [inaudible] DOT com o n n I t,
makers of Alpha Brain shroom,
tech sport shroom,
tech immune.
Get yourself some hemp protein son,
kettle bells,
both the ones we have available now and the super secret ones in battle ropes.
Get yourself some battle ropes.
Usually codenamed Brogan,
save 10% off any and all supplements and go to desk squad.tv if you want to pick
up one of these dope ass kitty cat tee shirts.
They were all over the place in Toronto.
Cool.
I saw a ton of them.
Those and the old school ones,
the uh,
and that goes to support Brian's death squad podcast network,
which is also a named desk squad,
which is on Itunes,
which is the only place to get the icehouse chronicles.
All right,
you fucking freaks.
Thanks to everybody for tuning into the podcast.
Thanks.
Everybody came out to Toronto at this past weekend.
It was fucking bananas.
Had a great time.
Thanks to Tripoli for hooking it up as well as already severe.
Ari's new CD comes out today,
Ladies and gentlemen.
So yeah,
the CD cover that,
have you seen that?
You go put it up,
put it up.
If you go to Ari Shaffir,
r on Twitter,
unknown code.
It says,
come on.
You know what I'm talking about Twitter while you're trying to pretend
I'm going blind.
Can't even read what I'm writing on Twitter.
If you go to [inaudible] website,
it'll show you how to get it.
You can get it from,
um,
his website,
which is already the great.com.
Or
eventually for the Holocaust.
He's a big juice.
Going back to him,
he wasn't hurt him,
but the Jews spider.
All right,
good night.
Can I shut it off?
You second mate.
[inaudible].